I READ YES THEY READY THEY'VE
BEEN READY I'M SORRY OKAY
ALL RIGHT WE WILL BEGIN
-- THE HEARING TODAY -- THANK
YOU FOR THE PATIENCE EVERYBODY
AND APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY'S HEARINGS
THAT WE HAD A BIT OF A DELAY
HERE OF COURSE WHICH IS I
JUST MENTIONED SO WE'RE GOING
TO ONLY HEAR THE FIRST TWO
ISSUES THE ISSUE ON DISTANCE
LEARNING IMPLEMENTATION
ALSO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN UNIVERSAL T.
K.
BEFORE THAT WE HAVE A
PRESENTATION ON THE STATE OF
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND EDUCATION
SYSTEMS AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH OUR KIDS DURING THIS OP
PANDEMIC AND THEN WITH THAT
WE WILL WITH ALL THOSE OTHER
ITEMS FOR A FUTURE HEARING
-- AGAIN TODAY'S AT SOCIALLY
DISTANCE HEARING WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ROOM WITH
THE ARE HERE AS WELL AS -- I
REMOTELY THROUGH THE ACCESS
LINE WE WE CAN WE CAN ANNOUNCE
THAT LATER IN THE HEARING --
THE FIRST PART OF THE HEARING
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
LIKE WE DID TWO WEEKS AGO ABOUT
-- EDUCATION DURING THE STATE
OF COVERT NINETEEN -- WE WILL
BE HEARING THE PROPOSALS AS FAR
AS WHAT WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET BUT THE BIG ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM OF COURSE IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH OUR SCHOOLS NOW
-- WE ARE IN NEGOTIATIONS THE
ASSEMBLY AND THIS IN THE SENATE
AS WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION
TO COME UP WITH THAT BUT THE
PLAN TO HELP RE OPENING OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS -- THERE COULD
BE A BILL IN PRINT AS EARLY AS
TODAY WHICH HAS BEEN OUTLINED
IN THE PAST FEW WEEKS PUBLICLY
AND HOPEFULLY THE PUBLIC WILL
HAVE MORE INFORMATION TO HEAR
ABOUT THAT LATER IN THE DAY --
YOU KNOW THAT THE KEY ELEMENTS
OF COURSE ARE OFFERED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND STABLE COHORTS
FOR STUDENTS IN MOST NEED
OF SUPPORT A PRIORITY FOR IN
PERSON COHORT FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS ARE
FOCUSING ON THE STUDENTS WHO
NEED THE MOST HELP CHRONICALLY
ABSENT STUDENTS FOSTER
YOUTH STRUGGLING AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND OTHERWISE
IDENTIFIED NEEDED TARGET
SCHOOLS -- WE HAVE A FOCUS
ON ALL SCHOOLS AND COUNTIES
IN THE RED TIER BETTER WITH
WITH LESS THAN EIGHT CASES
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND MUST
OFFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO
ALL STUDENTS IN K.
THREE SIX IN ADDITION TO THE K.
TWELVE COHORTS AND WE FOCUS
ON ENSURING THAT THAT --
ALL SCHOOLS MUST CONTINUE
TO ALLOW FAMILIES TO CHOOSE
CHOICE AGAIN BETWEEN DISTANCE
LEARNING FOR THEIR STUDENTS
OR IN PERSON SMALLER COHORTS
TO ADDRESS STUDENT AND FAMILY
NEEDS -- WE DO FOCUS AND ON
HOW WE WOULD ALLOCATE THE
MONEY THAT WAS OUTLINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S -- BUDGET IN
JANUARY THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION RECOVERY FUNDS AND THE
TWO BILLION FOR A RE OPENING
LASTLY FOR VACCINES WE PLAN
TO FOCUS ON HAVING OUR SCHOOLS
PUT ESSENTIAL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
FIRST IN LINE IN THE STATE'S
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION PROCESS
AS WE KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
WILL SET ASIDE A SIGNIFICANT
SHARE OF THE STATE'S VACCINES
TO SUPPORT GETTING ALL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES READY FOR SAFE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND AGAIN
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS IN
OUR COMMITTEE LAST FEW WEEKS
-- THIS COMMITTEE AND IT BUDGET
SUB SIX WE DO HOPE TO HAVE A
BILL THAT WE CAN VOTE ON IN THE
SUBS FOR BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
AND THE FULL ASSEMBLY IN THE
COMING DAYS -- SO WITH THAT I
KNOW PEOPLE WILL MAYBE WANT TO
ASK MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT ABOUT
THIS WE'RE NOT VOTING ON THIS
TODAY BY IS ONE OF TO IT TOOK
TO PUT IT OUT THERE THAT IS OF
COURSE WHAT EVERYONE'S TALKING
ABOUT TODAY'S REOPENING OUR
SCHOOLS SO IT'S HARD TO TALK
ABOUT THREE FOUR MONTHS AGO
AND WE'RE FOCUSING ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING TODAY -- SO WITH THAT
WE DO HAVE A A PRESENTATION
FIRST ROUND -- DR HEATHER HUGH
WHO'S A RESEARCHER FROM A PACE
AS WELL AS A DOCTOR HI THOMAS
-- MOLINO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATION
EXCELLENCE AND WILL BEGIN WITH
THEM FOCUSING ON THE STATUS
STUDENT OUTCOMES CALIFORNIA
THE COMMISSION
TWENTY TWO ANYTHING HERE
PLEASE BEGIN
HELLO THIS IS HEATHER HAVE
WITH PACE CAN YOU HEAR ME
HI THIS IS HEATHER HELP WITH
PACE CAN YOU HEAR ME OK RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY I'M HERE TODAY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION WHAT DO
WE KNOW ABOUT COPE WITH IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
A GREAT DAY TO INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU KNOW UNTIL FRIDAY WE
DIDN'T HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHICH SCHOOLS WERE OPENED OR
CLOSED WE DON'T HAVE A FORMULA
FOR DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENTS
THAT SCALE AND WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY STUDENTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ENROLLED IN
SCHOOL BY GRADE FOR SOCCER
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT STUDENT
EXPERIENCE AND STUDENT LEARNING
ALWAYS COMES FROM A SUBSET
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FROM
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA BUT USING
THIS INFORMATION WE CAN PAINT
A PRETTY CLEAR PICTURE OF THE
IMPACT OF CORPORATE NINETEEN ON
STUDENTS IN THE ELEVEN MONTHS
AND SCHOOLS AND ACTUALLY CLOSED
IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY SO I'M
GOING TO START WITH WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT COPING IMPACT ON
STUDENT LEARNING SINCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED RESEARCHERS
HAVE WORKED TO PROTECT
FIRST AND THEN TEST MAKE
IMPACT EXTENDED EDUCATIONAL
DISRUPTIONS ON STUDENT
LEARNING NATIONAL STUDIES
HAVE CONSISTENTLY SHOWN THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAS RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT SETBACKS IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH RESULTS
VERY QUITE SUBSTANTIALLY
DEPENDING ON THE SAMPLE A LARGE
PART THIS IS BECAUSE THERE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT -- RELATIONS
ACROSS STATE BUT ALSO DIFFERENT
CONTEXTS -- HOW STUDENTS
ARE BEING EDUCATED HOW MANY
STUDENTS WERE OUT OF SCHOOL
IN SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND IN THROUGH THE SUMMER
NOW THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF
VARIATION WITH MANY U.
S.
SCHOOLS IN PERSON WHILE THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
STUDENTS ARE STILL IN THE
LEARNING SO FOR THIS REASON
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
THE IMPACT OF ENDEMIC FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SKEPTICALLY
SO CASE WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT EDUCATION ANALYTICS AND
THE CORE DISTRICTS UTILIZED
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT DATA IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND IN
MATH OR FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN GRADES FOUR THROUGH TEN
AND EIGHTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT ARE PART OF THE CORE
DATA COLLABORATIVE THE FULL
COMMENTARY COPE WITH NINETEEN
AND EDUCATIONAL EQUITY CRISIS
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR HOMEPAGE
AT AT AT THE NCAA DOT WORK WE
ALSO MADE A SUMMARY HANDOUT
FOR THE HEARING IN OUR STUDY
LIKE OTHERS OF ITS KIND WE
COMPARE LEARNING RATES DURING
THE PANDEMIC TO LEARNING RATE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE OBSERVED
DURING THE PANDEMIC OR WHAT WE
CALL LEARNING LOSSES AND THE
SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
WOULD HOPE STUDENTS TO WHEN
A CUMULATE IN ANY GIVEN TIME
THAT THEY DIDN'T ACCUMULATE AS
A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC THE
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENTS WE USE
OUR MAP AND STARKEL COMPLETE
YOUR STANDARDS BASED AND DOCTOR
AND THEY WERE ADMINISTERED
BETWEEN AUGUST AND OCTOBER IN
ALICE THIS THAT I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY FIFTH BOTTOM
HAS MEASURING COPE WITH IMPACT
AT THE TIME THAT SCHOOL STARTED
ALL OVERALL WE FIND THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT LEARNING
LOSS IN BOTH ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS AND MATH WITH STUDENTS
IN GRADES FOUR THROUGH SIX
THE MOST IMPACTED ESTIMATES
VARY BY GRADE AND ASSESSMENT
BUT OUR ANALYSES SHOW THAT
STUDENTS NEEDS GREATER BEHIND
FIVE BETWEEN FIVE AND TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT BEHIND WHERE THEY
WOULD BE IN A TYPICAL YEAR
AVERAGES MASK VERY SERIOUS
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN STUDENT
GROUPS LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN
MOST RATES FOR BOTH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH AND
ACROSS BOTH ASSESSMENT PROCESS
SCHEDULING MORE LEARNING
TENDED HIGHER INCOME STUDENTS
IN SOME GRADES LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS LOST LEARNING WHILE
HIGHER INCOME STUDENTS LEARNING
ACTUALLY ACCELERATED AND FOR
STUDENTS LEARNING ENGLISH AND
NEARLY EVERY GRADE AND YEAH
IN THIS LANGUAGE ARTS AND
EARLY GRADES FOR MATH ACROSS
BOTH ASSESSMENTS THERE WAS
SUBSTANTIAL LEARNING LOSS
STUDENTS LEARNING ENGLISH
LOSING THIRTY PERCENT IN GRADE
FIVE OF A TYPICAL YEAR WELL
OTHER STUDENTS ONLY LOST ABOUT
TEN PERCENT SO THIS IS BOTH
SHOWING THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
BEING AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC
THAT SOME STUDENTS ARE BEING
AFFECTED MUCH MORE AND THIS IS
ON TOP OF WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
VERY PERSISTENT AND PERVASIVE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS BETWEEN GROUPS
THE WAY TO THINK ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THERE'S BEEN A FANNING OUT
OF IT SHE MADE GAPS AS A RESULT
THE PANDEMIC WITH SOME STUDENTS
FALLING VERY QUICKLY BEHIND
OTHER STUDENTS STAYING ON TRACK
OR FALLING BEHIND AT A LOWER
RATE BUT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHY WE'RE SEEING
THESE GAPS EMERGED DISTANCE
LEARNING REQUIRES A STABLE
HOME ENVIRONMENT HOUSING AND
FOOD SECURITY RELIABLE ACCESS
TO WIFI AND COMPUTERS AND AN
ADULT AT HOME TO SUPERVISE IN
THE EARLY GRADES WHEN STUDENTS
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO FOLLOW
DIRECTIONS OR NAVIGATE ONLINE
ASSIGNMENT FOR MANY STUDENTS
IN THE UPPER GRADES TWO DON'T
HAVE STRONG SELF MANAGEMENT
SKILLS OR WHO NEED SUPPORT TO
STAY ON TASK AND LEARNING THIS
IS CREATING A LARGE DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN HER LEGS STUDENTS
WHOSE FAMILIES CAN HIRE A FULL
TIME TUTOR OR EVEN A POTENTIAL
TEACHER WHO HAVE A PARENT AT
HOME FULL TIME AND OTHERS WHO
MAY NOT HAVE AN ADULT AT HOME
AT ALL OR ANY ADULT WHO DOESN'T
SPEAK ENGLISH OR DOES NOT HAVE
THE EDUCATION OR TRAINING TO
BE ABLE TO THE COURT LEARNING
OR TECHNOLOGY YEARS I MEAN
WE HAVE TO OF COURSE ACTIVE
TO THE DIFFERENTIAL IMPACT OF
THE VIRUS ITSELF WE KNOW THAT
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON BOTH HEALTH AND ECONOMICS
HAS BEEN BROUGHT BY CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES ARE LOW INCOME
BLACK AND LYFT NEXT COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE LESS ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE INCOME INEQUALITY AND
DISPROPORTIONATE EMPLOYMENT IN
HIGH RISK POSITIONS IT ALSO IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE THAT
STUDENTS CANNOT ACCESS LEARNING
THEIR BASIC NEEDS ARE MET AND
WE KNOW THAT SOME STUDENTS MAY
ALSO BE FACING OF LAPTOP USE OR
EVEN A COLLECTED HIGH WITHOUT
SCHOOLS TO STEP IN AND HELP
WITH THOSE NEEDS RIGHT MAYBE
THEY DID BEFORE WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SPECIFIC ISSUES
FOR STUDENTS LEARNING ENGLISH
AND THEY JUST ARE NOT LEARNING
ENGLISH REQUIRES OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS TO TALK WITH
EACH OTHER AND WITH CLASSMATES
WITHOUT THIS INTERACTION IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO LEARN
THE LANGUAGE AND WITHOUT THE
KIND OF SUPPORT FOR ACCESSING
GRADE LEVEL CONTENT IN ENGLISH
WILL BE VERY HARD FOR THEM TO
STAY ON GRADE LEVEL ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THAT BY DEFINITION THERE
AND HOME WORKING WHICH IS NOT
SPOKEN AND SO THE ADULT THERE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO HELP WITH
CONTENT STILL RELEASED FINDINGS
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO SIMILARLY FACE YOU NEED
TO BUT SIMILAR CHALLENGES HAVE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLANS WHICH
DETAIL THE KIND OF SPECIALIZED
SERVICES THAT STUDENTS NEED AND
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT PARENTS WILL
HAVE THE TYPES OF SKILLS AND
TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
THOSE SERVICES A RECENT SURVEY
SHOWED THAT THIRTY NINE PERCENT
OF PARENTS WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE
THESE INDIVIDUALIZED PLANS
RECORDED THAT THEY'RE NOT
RECEIVING ANY SUPPORT AT ALL
IN OUR ANALYSIS WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT A LARGE PROPORTION
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WERE MISSING AND ALMOST NOT
MUCH RAISES CONCERNS ABOUT --
WHO IS BEING ASSESSED AND WHAT
THAT MEANS ABOUT THESE KINDS
OF LEARNING LAS ASSESSMENTS ARE
GENERALLY THIS ISSUE OF MISSING
STUDENTS IS A HUGE CONCERN
BECAUSE WE'RE COMPLETELY
BLIND TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THEM I DON'T KNOW IF
MAKING DISENGAGEMENT SCHOOL
AND HIGHER EARLY IF THEY MOVED
AWAY IF THEY'RE IN A CHARTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM HOME SCHOOL
PROGRAM OR PRIVATE SCHOOL OR IF
THEY'RE OKAY AT ALL IF THEY'RE
MISSING FROM THE ASSESSMENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE DISENGAGED FROM
SCHOOL ALTOGETHER THE OVERALL
IMPACT ON STUDENT LEARNING
IS MUCH MORE DIRE THAN OUR
ANALYSIS SHOWS IN ALMOST EVERY
ANALYSIS OF LEARNING THAT
I'VE SEEN THERE'S TYPICALLY
BETWEEN TEN AND TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
MISSING ACT THOSE STUDENTS
ARE NOT RECEIVING ANY KIND
OF INSTRUCTION ON MUCH BIGGER
PROBLEM THAN ANY ANALYSIS HAS
SHOWN US FAR AND WE KNOW THAT
ENROLLMENT OVERALL IS DOWN
PREVIOUS ANALYSIS BY CD EASTER
JUST THAT STATEWIDE ENROLLMENT
IS DOWN A HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND ALICE'S
FROM SOME OF OUR STATE'S
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS SHOWS
THAT KINDERGARTEN ENROLLMENT
IS DOWN NEARLY TWENTY PERCENT
INCREASE SCHOOL ENROLLMENT IS
DOWN TO THERE'S MORE REASON
TO BE VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE
EARLY GRADES I THINK STUDENTS
RE ENROLL IN FALL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DUSTER KINDERGARTEN AND
FIRST GRADE VERY FAR BEHIND
AND EVEN FOR THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
DISTANCE LEARNING IS GENERALLY
HARDEST FOR THE YOUNGEST
STUDENTS IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO PAY ATTENTION MAKE
GENERALLY LEARN THROUGH PLAY
AN ENGAGEMENT LETTER LACKING
ANYTHING CLASSROOMS AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO BUILD BASIC
SKILLS LIKE REALLY LITERACY AND
NUMERACY WITHOUT TEACHER AND
PEER INTERACTION WELL WE DON'T
HAVE GREAT DATA ON EARLY GRADE
LEARNING AT SCALE HE DOES HAVE
AN UPCOMING ANALYSIS SHOWING
THAT STUDENTS READING CURRENCY
IN SECOND AND THIRD GRADE IS
SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND BUT WE
WOULD EXPECT IN A TYPICAL YEAR
STUDENTS IN NEED EARLY GRADES
DON'T DEVELOP BASIC SKILLS IT
WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
ACCESS FUTURE BUT WE ALSO HAVE
REASON TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
UPPER GRADE STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE -- TROUBLING SIGNS
THAT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE
NOT ENGAGING WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING IN SACRAMENTO CITY
TEN TIMES MORE STUDENTS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY DISENGAGED
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR D.
AND F.
GRADES ARE INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY ACROSS THE
STATE ESPECIALLY FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED THE NUMBER
OF TEETH IN ASTON BREAK NINE
THROUGH TWELVE INCREASED BY
EIGHT POINT SEVEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS IN THE FALL COMPARED
TO THE PRIOR YEAR WITH THE
GREATEST INCREASE AMONG BLACK
NOT BLACK AND LATIN ACCIDENTS
AND RESEARCH CONSISTENTLY SHOWS
THAT TRANSITION YEARS BETWEEN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
AND INTO POSTSECONDARY ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS SO IT
WILL BE CRITICAL TO GET THEM
BACK ON TRACK AND IT ISN'T
JUST ACHIEVEMENT STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH IS SUFFERING AS WELL
RATES OF DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
ARE UP NATIONWIDE AS WELL AS
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS AND STUDENTS
NINE DISCONNECTED FROM SCHOOL
AND FROM RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR PEERS AND EDUCATORS SO
HE'S A VERY INTENSE PICTURE BUT
IT'S NOT MEANT TO BE FATALISTIC
RATHER FOR US TO GIVE YOU A
REALISTIC ABOUT INSIST THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE HAPPENING WE NEED
TO LAY THE GROUNDWORK NOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THESE
DEFICIENCIES AND THE WIDENING
UP NEEDS GAPS THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC WE NEED ASSESSMENTS AT
SCALE WE NEED A ROBUST SYSTEM
UP EQUITY INDICATORS TO MONITOR
HOW OUR SYSTEMS ARE PERFORMING
FOR STUDENTS WE NEED A LARGE
INVESTMENT NOW AND INTO THE
FUTURE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T GO BACK TO NORMAL BECAUSE
NORMAL WAS ALREADY NOT SERVING
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE TO A
LARGE DEGREE AND WE HAVE A VERY
HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF STUDENT
NEED SO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THESE ISSUES AND OR TO
THAT CONVERSATION THANK YOU
DR MOLINO
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES THANK YOU PERFECT
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FIRST I WANT TO THANK EACH OF
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP DURING
THE ACADEMIC NO IT'S NOT AN
INCREDIBLE THAT'S FOR EVERYONE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP I
VALUE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
PUBLICLY AS CHAIR STATEWIDE
TRENDS AND STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
NEEDS DURING THE PANDEMIC CAN
ALSO IDENTIFY SUPPORTS THAT WE
PROVIDED AT CC AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH OTHER AGENCIES TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS I THOUGHT IT BEST
IF WE START WITH THE DATA
THAT WE DO HAVE THE NEWS FOLKS
ARE AWARE WE DID NOT HAVE
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT RESULTS
IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY SCHOOL
YEAR DUE TO THE SUSPENSION
STATEWIDE TESTING IN THE SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY BUT I BELIEVE
THERE'S VALUE IN TAKING JUST
A FEW MINUTES TAKE A QUICK
LOOK BACK TO THE PRE CODE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SCHOOL YEAR
RESULTS ONCE ON THE DASHBOARD
ALL TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
OVERALL THE PERFORMANCE AT
THAT TIME SHOWED SOME SMALL
INCREASES IN PARTICULAR ON
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION AND
BRIEFLY IN SOME TEST SCORERS
YEAH IN OTHER AREAS SUCH AS
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM THE DATA
WORSENED STATEWIDE TWELVE
POINT ONE PERCENT OF STUDENTS
TESTED IN OUR STATE YES MORE
THAN TEN PERCENT OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN
THE RANGE WAS FROM FOUR POINT
FIVE PERCENT PRAIRIES MERICAN
STUDENTS WERE CHRONICALLY
ABSENT COMPARED TO TWENTY
TWO POINT FIVE PERCENT OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM WAS
AN ISSUE FOR US PRIOR AND FOR
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE ANYONE OF
SIGNIFICANCE CONCERNS AND OUR
STUDENTS WILL NEED TO BE RE
ENGAGED ONCE WERE ABLE TO GET
BACK TO SCHOOL THE NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS AT THAT TIME WERE
DESIGNATED UNDER OUR STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM FOR WHAT
WE CALL DIFFERENTIATING THE
SYSTEMS SYSTEMS FELL TO THREE
THIRTY THREE WHICH IS A FORTY
PERCENT FEWER THAN THE PRIOR
YEAR DISQUALIFICATION JUST
PROVIDES ELEAZAR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT MOSTLY THROUGH
COUNTY OFFICES BUT ALSO THE
SUPPORT OF THE C.
C.
IN THE DEPARTMENT IS DESIRED
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OAKLAND UNIFIED
SAC CITY UNIFIED MOUNT DIABLO
UNIFIED AND SALINAS UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT'S LOWEST
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE WERE SET
IN MOTION A NEW REQUIREMENT
AND AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO OUR
SYSTEMIC CONSTRUCTION REVIEW
BY OUR REGION SINCE THE SEA
TO HELP DETERMINE THE SUPPORTS
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THOSE STUDENTS ALL FOR
THESE DISTRICTS QUALIFIED
FOR ALMOST STUDENTS IN A
COMBINATION OF FOSTER STUDENTS
ENGLISH LEARNERS STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND FOR
OAKLAND MOUNT DIABLO AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS OVERALL
ACROSS THE STATE STUDENTS
WHO ARE MOST FREQUENTLY
IDENTIFIED FOR ELIGIBILITY AT
THAT TIME WERE OUR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES OUR FOSTER
YOUTH ARE HOMELESS OUR SOCIO
ECONOMIC DISADVANTAGE STUDENTS
ARE ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREAS OF
GRADUATION CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
SUSPENSIONS ACADEMIC ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PERFORMANCE INDICATORS
AS WELL AS GRADUATION I SURE
THE STATE WOULD YOU SINCE IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE RECENT DATED
RESEARCH PROJECTS PROJECTS THE
IMPACTS LOCAL WITH NINETEEN
AND DEMOCRATS AND IS MANY WAYS
CONTINUE TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
AREN'T COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND RESULTING IN FURTHER IN
EQUITIES AND ACCESS TO THEIR
EDUCATION ARE HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED STUDENT POPULATIONS
HAVE BEEN SPECIALLY VULNERABLE
AREAS BARRIERS TO LEARNING
INCLUDING LACK OF ACCESS
TO THE DEVICE OR RELIABLE
INTERNET AND UNMET NEEDS FOR
DIRECT IN SMALL GROUPS COURT
ELEAZAR HISTORICALLY CONFRONTED
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
UNDER THE BEST OF CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE ENCOUNTERING EXASPERATED
DISPARITIES THAT IMPACT
STUDENTS ACADEMICS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL SAFETY
NEEDS STATE NATIONAL DATA FROM
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS PACE AND
WTA AND CDC CHAU CONTINUED BE
TO SUPPORT STUDENT LEARNING
ACCELERATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
BUT UNITS THROUGH STATE IN
SUPPORT OF ENVIRONMENTS FIRST
HEATHER SHARED SOME OF THE IN
RECENT FINDINGS WITH THE CORE
DISTRICTS THAT IDENTIFY THESE
LEARNING GAPS IN PRIOR YEARS
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE INCREASE
OF THESE INEQUITIES WHEN AS
WE LOOK AT FURTHER RESEARCH
IN SOME OF THE DATA ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE NATION'S QUITE
SOBERING INTERPACE RESEARCH
WITH THE CORE DISTRICTS
THE NORTHWEST EVALUATION
ASSOCIATION NWEA RELEASED THEIR
ASSESSMENT RESULTS WILL FALL
TWENTY TWENTY DATA AND THEN W.
AID BACK WORLD TEST TAKEN BY
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS IN GRADES
THIRD TO EIGHT AND OVER A
THOUSAND SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES INCLUDING MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
AIRED IN THE SAME GRADE
STUDENTS IN FALL TWO THOUSAND
NINE STUDENTS IN GRADES THIRD
THROUGH EIGHT IN FALL TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SURPRISINGLY
FOUND THAT STUDENTS HAD SIMILAR
PERCENTILE SCORES IN READING
CANNOT SEE IS LARGELY DROPPING
READING ASSIGNMENT PREDICTED
HOWEVER PERCENTILES FOR MAPS
WERE CONSIDERABLY LOWER ON
AVERAGE FOR STUDENTS THIS YEAR
AS COMPARED TO SUMMER GRADE
STUDENTS PRIOR YEAR WELL MOST
GROUPS SO STABLE PERFORMANCE
RATING SLIGHT IMPROVEMENTS
OVER THE HALL IN SOME OF THE
READING SMALL DROPS CONTINUE
TO BE OBSERVED IN READING FOR
BLACK AND HISPANIC STUDENTS
IN THE UPPER ELEMENTARY
GRADES IN MATH THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY STUDENTS IN ALL ETHNIC
RACIAL GROUPS THAT LOWER
PERCENTILE SCORES COMPARED TO
THE SAME GRADE STUDENTS ALL
I WAS NINETEEN IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT AND W.
EA CLARIFIED THAT THE RANGE
OF STUDENT GROUPS ASSESSED
IS ACTUALLY LESS THAN THE
PRIOR YEAR AND THAT STUDENTS
WHO TEND TO BE THE MOST
UNDERSERVED START INCLUDING
ARE HOMELESS FOSTER YOUTH AND
ENGLISH LEARNERS OR A LARGER
PART OF THIS GROUP THAT WERE
MISSING IN SOME OF THE DATA
EDUCATION WEEK CONDUCTED A
NATIONAL SURVEY FROM SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TO OCTOBER EIGHTH
TWENTY TWENTY ON SEVERAL TOPICS
INCLUDING ISSUES RELATED TO
ABSENCES ACROSS THE NATION
STUDENT ABSENCES HAVE DOUBLED
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE NUMBERS
SUGGESTED HIGH SCHOOLERS ARE
SLIGHTLY MORE LIKELY TO BE
ABSENT ABOUT THIRTEEN PERCENT
A TYPICAL DAY IN THE MIDDLE
ELEVEN PERCENT ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLERS AND NINE PERCENT
AND ACCORDING TO THE SURVEY
ABSENTEEISM RATES ARE HIGHER
FOR SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS AND
STUCK WITH FULL TIME REMOTE
LEARNING BUT THEY'RE ALSO IN
SCHOOLS WHO ARE PROVIDING FULL
TIME SPOT IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
OR NEXT TO THE MALL AND IN
PERSON LEARNING COMPARED TO
PRIOR YEARS RESEARCH CONTINUES
TO SHOW IN SCHOOLS FOR MORE
THAN HALF THE STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED IN TREATING REDUCE
LUNCH PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE
MORE LIKELY SEVENTY PERCENT TO
HOLD STUDENTS BACK IN RESPONSE
TIMES EXCUSED ABSENCES AND
SCHOOLS WERE FEWER THAN HALF
METER ALSO THE COMPRESSIONAL
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW
SINCE CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
WAS RESPONSIBLE THE MAJORITY
OF DISTRICTS WOULD QUALIFY
FOR DIFFERENT CITIES SYSTEMS
ARE CALIFORNIA DASHBOARD
TWO THOUSAND NINETY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ALSO REPORTING
LESS STUDENT ENROLLMENT OVERALL
AND MANY HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
THAT WHEN THEY RETURN TO SCHOOL
FOURTEEN SCHOOL INSTRUCTION AT
UP TO TEN TO FIFTEEN PERCENT
OF THEIR STUDENTS WILL BE GONE
A NATIONAL SURVEY OF FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PARENTS CONDUCTED BY
THE PARENTS TOGETHER AND MADE
TWENTY TWENTY RECORDED TWENTY
PERCENT OF PARENTS WHOSE
CHILDREN HAVE IN I.
ETT SO THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
THOSE SERVICES AND THAT THIRTY
NINE PERCENT WERE NOT RECEIVING
ANY SCORED ALL CHILDREN WHO
QUALIFY FOR INDIVIDUAL LEARNING
PLANS WILL ALSO TWICE AS LIKELY
AS IT APPEARS TO BE DOING
LITTLE OR NO REMOTE LEARNING
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT VERSUS
SEVENTY PERCENT IT'S A STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES WERE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO SAY DISTANCE
LEARNING IS GOING POORLY FORTY
PERCENT VERSUS NINETY PERCENT
OF THOSE WITHOUT IDPS PARENTS
WERE ALMOST TWICE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH UP FORTY PERCENT VERSUS
TWENTY THREE PERCENT WELL MAYBE
PRELIMINARY POSITIVE NOTE THE
NATIONAL STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE
RESEARCH SURVEY SHOWED LITTLE
EVIDENCE TO CALL THE NINETEEN
IMPACTED HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
HOWEVER THE PANDEMIC IMPACTING
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES IN THEIR
IMMEDIATE COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
AND ALSO HIGH POVERTY LOW
INCOME IN URBAN HIGH SCHOOLS
I THINK THAT THE HARDEST THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ENROLLING IN
COLLEGE IMMEDIATELY AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL IS PLUNGED NEARLY TWENTY
TWO PERCENT THIS FOLLOWED LAST
YEAR ENDING OUR HIGHEST POVERTY
IN URBAN SCHOOLS THE HARDEST
AND THE NEEDIEST STUDENTS
CONTINUAL STRUGGLE THE MOST
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT OF GRADUATES
IN HIGH POVERTY SCHOOLS DROPPED
THIRTY TWO POINT SIX PERCENT
COMPARED WITH SIXTEEN POINT
FOUR PERCENT BELOW POVERTY
SCHOOLS IN ADDITION A ROMAN
FELL BY TWENTY SIX POINT
FOUR PERCENT SCHOOLS A LARGE
PROPORTION OF UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITIES COMPARED WITH
EIGHTEEN PERCENT LOW MINORITY
HIGH SCHOOLS AND DECREASED
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OR BINS
NINETY PERCENT SUBURBAN AND
EIGHTY PERCENT REALIZE SCHOOLS
THE TWENTY ONE POINT SEVEN
DECLINED IMMEDIATE COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT HIGH SCHOOLS ALL
TWENTY TWENTY NEARLY EIGHT
TIMES TO TREAT ENDEMIC LOS
THIS MAY CHANGE THIS YEAR WHEN
SOUTHERN MANSIONS MANY SCHOOLS
ARE REPORTING AND HANDING
OUT MORE DECENT ESTIMATE IN
THE SPRING SCHOOLS NATIONWIDE
ACROSS DISTRICTS SUCH AS --
UNIFIED SERVICES CAN UNIFIED
RECENTLY IDENTIFIED IN THE
ARTICLE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY ARE SEEING A
SURGE IN POOR GRADES FEEL ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC THIS TREND IS IN
LINE WITH SCHOOL OFFICIALS AND
NATIONAL EXPERTS CONNECTIONS
AT SCHOOL COLLEGES LONG WITHOUT
SCHOOLS ONLINE EDUCATION A FEW
EXAMPLES IN CALIFORNIA THESE
ENOUGH MADE UP THIRTY PERCENT
OF GRADES IN ESCONDIDO UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT ON THE
FIRST GRADING I'M NOT INCREASED
TO THIRTY SIX PERCENT IN THE
SECOND AND ALWAYS UNIFIED ROAM
THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS ARE
ATTENDING SCHOOL IN PERSON
THAT'S GREAT FOR MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS MORE
THAN DOUBLED COMPARED TO
THE SAME TIME LAST YEAR AND
ACROSS NOT UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT CHRISTENSEN ATTEND
IN PERSON CLASSES FOR UP TO
ONE DAY A WEEK THIRTY ONE
PERCENT THE GRADES DURING THE
FIRST QUARTER WERE D.
OR F.
GRADES SCHOOL LEADERS HAVE
SHARED WITH A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF THE STUDENTS SPECIALLY IN
THE UPGRADES ARE DOING WELL
IN DISTANCE LEARNING BUT OTHER
STUDENTS WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY
DONE WELL IN SCHOOL ARE
ALSO NOW STRUGGLING AND MOST
OFTEN WITH THE LACK OF SOCIAL
INTERACTION SUGGESTING A
STRONG FOCUS NEEDS TO SUPPORT
STUDENT LEARNING ACCELERATION
AND THAT'LL HELP THE WELL
MISTER SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS IN ADDITION THESE
FINDINGS RELATED TO PANDEMIC
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY WITH WITH THOSE FROM
WHOM SOME FOLKS FROM HURRICANE
KATRINA WHO SURVIVED SOME OF
THOSE STUDIES AND RESPONSE
PROVIDED SOME IMPORTANT
INSIGHTS THAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO
STUDENTS WHO WERE DISPLACED AND
LEAD TO MOVE AT LOWER ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND WE'RE THE ONES
WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO ENGAGE
IN NEGATIVE BEHAVIORS SCHOOL
STUDENTS ON AVERAGE MORE THAN
TWO YEARS BELOW GRADE LEVEL
SOME MUCH MORE LOSSES WERE MOST
AMERICAN MATHEMATICS WHICH IS
SIMILAR TO THE TRENDS WE'RE
SEEING IN CALIFORNIA DEGREE
OF LEARNING GAPS ARE NOT ONLY
PROTECTED BY FAMILY INCOME
PRIOR SCHOOL STUDENT H.
OR PRETREATED THE GRADE LEVEL
ALL SCHOOLS AND OPEN IN NEW
ORLEANS AFTER KATRINA NEED
THE RESOURCES AND TRAINING
PROCESS INDIVIDUAL READINESS
TO RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF
THE GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL BASIS
STUDENTS TENDED TO TRICKLE BACK
TO CAL NEW ORLEANS NEW ORLEANS
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
AND THEREFORE SCHOOLS COULD
NEVER STOP ASSESSING ADJUSTING
TO LEARNING LOSS OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS AND OFTEN TOOK
MULTIPLE YEARS DID INITIALIZE
INTENTION TO RESOLVE THE
LARGEST LEARNING GAPS SCHOOLS
TRIED VARIOUS APPROACHES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AND THE FINDINGS SHOW THAT
SCHOOL STRUGGLE TO KNOW HOW
TO USE DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENTS
TO DETERMINE STUDENT READY
THIS FOR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
STUDENTS WHO ARE SCIENTISTS
DISMISSED SPECIALLY DESIGNED
TUTORING OR INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT IN ADDITION TO THEIR
GRADE LEVEL INSTRUCTION OR
ABLE TO ACCELERATE READING
AND MATH LEVELS TEACHERS WHO
WERE ABLE TO STAY WITH THEIR
SAME STUDENTS FROM MORE THAN
ONE YEAR MADE SIGNIFICANT
GAINS HIGH SCHOOLS FOUNDED
STUDENTS OFTEN WERE BORED
AND PURELY REMEDIAL CLASSES
AND DID NOT MAKE PROGRESS AS
WEAPONS DEVELOPMENT JOURNEY
LEVEL STUDENTS STUDENTS WERE
THEN ASSIGNED TO REGULAR GRADE
LEVEL COURSES HIGH SCHOOLS
INCLUDED ALL OF WHAT THEY CALL
SPIRALING WHERE I TEACHERS
WOULD PRESENT REGULAR COURSE
MATERIAL AFTER WE TEACHING PRE
REQUISITE MATERIALS AT SOME
STUDENTS HAD MISSED OFTEN SHOW
GAINES HIGH SCHOOLS ARRANGE
FOR TUTORING FOR STUDENTS WHO
NEED EXTRA HELP KEEPING UP
INSPIRING COURSES CHAU GAINS
AS WELL AND HIGH SCHOOLS
FOUNDED SPIRALING GREATLY
IMPROVES STUDENTS PERSISTENCE
AT SCHOOL GRADUATION ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS EMPHASIZE MOSTLY SKILL
RECOVERY THROUGH MEDIATION
FOUNDED STUDENTS TEND TO SCORE
POORLY IN STATE ACCOUNTABILITY
TEST AND CONTINUE TO FALL
BEHIND ON THE GRADE LEVEL
CONTENT CONSEQUENT WE EMPHASIS
ON GRADE LEVEL INSTRUCTION
APPROVED SCORE PERFORMANCE
MOST IMPORTANTLY WHAT THEY
FOUND TO TREAT IS THAT THE
SCHOOLS WERE UNPREPARED FOR
THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS
STUDENTS IN THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS WE'RE SEEING
A SIMILAR PATTERN HERE CAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS NOTED IN
A RECENT GUIDANCE AND EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
WERE GROWING CONCERN BEFORE
THE CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
ZONE EXASPERATED BECAUSE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE AN INSTANCE
OVERWHELMING AT THE PANDEMIC
IS DELTA PARTICULARLY HARD
CLOAK STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH
AND WELL BEING INCREASING
SOCIAL ISOLATION DISRUPTING
ROUTINES AND A LIMITING SCHOOL
TRADITIONS AND RITES OF PASSAGE
WHILE ALSO REDUCING STUDENTS
ACCESS TO SCHOOLS WHICH SERVE
AS A DE FACTO MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS
OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
ALSO FACING ECONOMIC KNOW
THE CHALLENGES CRISIS STEEPER
STILL ACCORDING TO THE CDC THE
PROPORTION CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS AMONG OUR PEDIATRIC
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS INCREASED
COMPARED TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FOR SOME MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
THIS IS FOR CHILDREN AGES FIVE
ELEVEN AND TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN
YEARS INCREASED APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FOUR AND THIRTY ONE
PERCENT RESPECTIVELY A STUDENT
SURVEY AND CONDUCTED BY THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS THE SPOT
START OF THE PANDEMIC OWN
RISING RATES OF ADOLESCENT
STUDENTS REPORTED NEEDED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND THE CLIENT
REPORTED WELLNESS FROM SIXTY
FIVE PERCENT TO LESS THAN
FORTY PERCENT TWENTY THREE
PERCENT OF STUDENTS WAITED TOO
MANY MENTAL HEALTH WELLNESS
AND LEVEL REQUIRING IMMEDIATE
INTERVENTION CONTINUED
SUICIDES CONTINUE TO BE ON
THE RISE THERE'S A REALLY
STRONG ARGUMENT THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT SUPPORT AND WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR STUDENTS AND FOR
THE EDUCATORS WHO SERVE THEM
NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED FIRST ON
STRATEGIES AND SUPPORTS TO
RE ENGAGE STUDENTS TO SCHOOL
WITH A FOCUS ON THEIR SOCIAL
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING TO
ESTABLISH SETTINGS WITH THEIR
ACADEMIC NEEDS CAN THAT BE MATT
THIS WILL REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES INCLUDING SOCIAL
WORKERS COUNSELORS NURSES AND
OTHER EFFORTS TO ENSURE THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS TO ENGAGE
IN LEARNING ABOUT FIRST BEFORE
WE DIVE DIRECTLY INTO ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR TEACHERS IN
YOUR DOLLS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN WILL
NEED TO RESOURCES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS AS WELL AS THEMSELVES
STARTING WITH THE TIME TO
RE ENGAGE BEFORE JUMPING
INTERVENTIONS FOCUSED SOLELY
ON THE ACADEMIC NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN NEXT SECTION WHEN I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SHARE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING IT THE CECE'S AND STUFF
AND I'M -- AS MOST FOLKS IN
THE IN MARCH AS ENDEMIC HERE
WE RECESSED AT THAT TIME AND
PIVOTED TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT
THE FO'C'SLE WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH CHILDREN AT THE ONSET WE
REACHED OUT TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WILL DETERMINE THE MOST URGENT
SUPPORTS FOR THE HIGH NEED
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
IDENTIFIED IN THE SCHOOL
DASHBOARD THE COLLECTIVE GOAL
WAS TO COLLABORATE AND RAPPER
RESPONSE NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
STUDENT AGENT ASSESS LEARNING
PROGRESS EXPAND PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING IN TRADES TRANSACTION
FOR THE SAFE RETURN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FROM MARCH
TO JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE DAHLE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
RESOURCES IN COLLABORATION
WITH DELEGATES INCLUDING
COUNTY OFFICES SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS AS WELL
AS OTHER AGENCIES AND OUR
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT PARTNERS
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND SAY WHAT
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS FOR EXAMPLE WE
CREATED RESOURCES SUCH AS THE
CONTINUITY OF LEARNING PLAY
BOOKS WHICH FOCUS OUR RESOURCES
SUPPORT DISTANCE LEARNING HARD
READING IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
WE DEVELOPED A DISTANCE
LEARNING CONSORTIUM FOR COUNTY
OFFICES TO BUILD ONLINE LESSONS
AND SUBJECT AREAS AND GRADE
LEVELS INCLUDING LCL RESOURCES
THAT WERE AVAILABLE TO ALL BE
CREATED XCELERATED LEARNING
SERIES WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
SOME OF OUR LOWEST PERFORMING
ELEAZAR AND ALSO COUNTY
OFFICE JUST HELP THEM AS
THEY SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS
TO ACCELERATE OUR RECENTLY
WE'VE DEVELOPED OUR FIELD
GUIDE FOR ACCELERATED LEARNING
EQUITY AND WELL BEING SUPPORT
RALLY AS WITH MAXIMIZING
EQUITY STRENGTHENING SYSTEMS
INSTRUCTIONS AND LEVERAGING
HIGH QUALITY INSTRUCTION
THESE FREE ONLINE PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
ASSESSED ACCESS BY TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND CLASSIFIED
STATE WIDE LAST YEAR WE PUT ON
TOLD THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT VIRTUAL SESSIONS OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS
OVER THREE THOUSAND DELEGATES
THAT PARTICIPATED WE CONTINUE
ALSO REMAIN IN THE ON GOING
DIRECT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
RECEIVE EMERGENCY PORTION
RENTS ARE ELIGIBLE TO SUPPORT
BASED ON THE STUDENT ARTS ON
THE DASHBOARD THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER DURING A PANDEMIC OUR
ONGOING SUPPORT IS INCLUDING
YOUR DRESSING DISTANCE LEARNING
STUDENT GROUP BEING SINGLE
COGNITIVE LEARNING WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH THOSE DISTRICTS
LASTLY WE'RE EXCITED THAT
WE HAVE LAUNCHED ON JANUARY
TWENTY FIFTH WHAT WE CALL
OUR LEADING FORWARD SERIES
THIS IS AN INITIATIVE THAT
PROVIDES TOOLS FOR EDUCATORS
LEADERS AND SCHOOL COMMUNITY
STAKE HOLDERS TO RE ENGAGE
STUDENTS ACCELERATE LEARNING
WELL DANCE IN EQUITY FOR OUR
VULNERABLE STUDENT GROUPS
ENSURING THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING
THE WHOLE CHILD THE DESIGN OF
THESE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
INITIATIVES BASED ON FIVE
FOCUS AREAS FIRST DRIVING
SOCIAL MOSTLY HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITIES TOOLS AND
SUPPORTS A THRIVING -- SOCIAL
EMOTIONALLY AND ACADEMICALLY
USE THE FORMATIVE ASSESSMENTS
ARE WE MEASURE STUDENT NEEDS
IN PROGRESS TO ENSURE WE'RE
SUPPORTING THE WHOLE CHILD
EVERY DISTANCE LEARNING I'VE
BEEN LEARNING AS WELL AS
WE REAL SCHOOLS HOW DO WE
CREATE RESPONSIVE TEACHING
AND LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
WHAT'S CONSTRUCTION LOOK LIKE
IN ORDER TO ENSURE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERY
STUDENT HOW DO WE SUPPORT
SYSTEM LEADERSHIP ABOUT HIGHER
DISTRICT LEVEL FROM OUR ROLES
IS CLASSROOM RICHARD PETERS
SCHOOL LEADERS PARENTS AND
FAMILY YEARS TO TRULY WORK
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THE CHILD
TO THE WHOLE SYSTEM AND HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT ALL THIS IS DONE
THROUGH ADVANCING ACCORDING TO
MAINTAIN A FOCUS ON ADVANCING
EQUITY FOR STUDENTS SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES TO DISCOURAGE
OF CONTINUED TESTING CYBER
LEARNING AS WE PREPARE FOR
A RETURN TO SCHOOL AND JUST
TWO WEEKS SINCE THE LAUNCH
WE HAD OVER SIX THOUSAND IS
VERY ACCESS THIS COLLECTION
OF KEYNOTES COURSES TOOLS AND
SESSIONS SHARE THIS WITH YOU
BECAUSE THE NEEDS ARE GREAT
AND SO CERTAIN CHANNELS LIKE
YOU FOR RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THEM AS THEY TRY TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS I LEAVE YOU TODAY WITH
THREE STRONG RECOMMENDATIONS
TO CONSIDER FIRST SUPPORT DALY
AS WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
INCLUDE ACCESS TO RESEARCH
AND TRAINING AND THAT ADOPTS A
PHASED IN APPROACH TO RE ENGAGE
STUDENTS THAT PRIORITIZES
STUDENT SOCIAL HOLES MOTIONAL
HEALTH AND PHYSICAL SAFETY
NEEDS FIRST CONDITION INCLUDE
STRUCTURES RALLY IS TO FOCUS
ON PAYER CONNECTIONS STRENGTHEN
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH TEACHERS
AND DEEPLY ENGAGE WITH THE
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES WILL
SPENT THE LAST YEAR CO TEACHING
THEIR CHILDREN AT HOME THEY
ALSO INVEST IN TRAINING TO
SUPPORT ACCELERATION INTO
YOUR SUPPORT TO ALLOW STUDENTS
ACCESS GRADE LEVEL CURRICULUM
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS NEEDED
TO ACCELERATE THEIR LEAD
LEARNING WITH A LESSER LINES ON
WOULD BE THE ASIAN I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE I
ALSO HAVE THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
MY COLLEAGUES COLORS STRADA
DISTRIBUTION YOUR AVAILABLE
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I THINK THAT WAS A PRETTY
THOROUGH EXAMINATION CURRENT
STATE OF ONLINE EDUCATION STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PRETTY ACCURATE
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE -- I THINK
IN IN THE WORDS OF MY HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ONLINE LEARNING
SUCKS RIGHT -- STUDENTS ARE
NOT ENGAGED STUDENTS ARE NOT
PERFORMING WELL ACADEMICALLY
AND WHAT'S UNUSUAL -- GIVEN
OUR HISTORY OUR DATA IT IS
NOT JUST ANY LONGER THOSE
STUDENTS THAT FALL UNDER A
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS RIGHT THE TIME ONCE
YOU IS RIGHT TYPICALLY WE KNOW
THAT THOSE STUDENTS COME WITH
MORE CHALLENGES BUT TODAY IT
IS A LOT MORE STUDENTS THAN
YESTERDAY SO -- THIS IS GONNA
TAKE A LOT OF A LOT OF WORK
A LOT OF LEARNING RECAPTURE
LEARNING LOSS EVERYONE
CALLED RUNNING OF IT TURNER
LEARNING OR CAPTURE IS A
TERM PRETTY SOON -- BUT IT'S
IT'S IT'S SIGNIFICANT AND --
THE UNDERSCORES WELL WAS THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL IMPACT OF THE
SITUATION WHEN I WAS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER YOU KNOW I'M
HEARING IT FROM MY COLLEAGUES
RIGHT AND THEN MY OWN HOUSE
I TO HIGH SCHOOL KIDS AND --
I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT WORKING
IT'S YOU KNOW SO I K.
I CONCUR WITH EVERYTHING'S
BEEN SAID -- YOU KNOW NEED
TO BEAT A DEAD HORSE -- IS
NOW OUR OBLIGATION TO DRAFT A
RESPONSE TO THE SITUATION OF
RIGOROUS RESPONSE AND CERTAINLY
IT INCLUDES SCHOOLS GETTING
RE OPEN IN A SAFE MANNER ROSE
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS BUT --
AND GETTING THEM OPEN -- IS
KEY IT IS KEY SO I THANK YOU
-- FOR THE PRESENTATIONS THE
BOTH THE YOU DON'T NEED TO
BE LABOR THE POINTS THAT YOU
MADE YOU MADE THEM WELL AND
I THINK BACK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU MR MEDINA I'M HAPPY TO --
FOLLOW MY COLLEAGUES FROM LONG
BEACH THE STRUGGLE BEING ALSO A
FORMER CLASS AS HE WAS AND AND
-- YOU KNOW YOU PRESENTATION
WAS THOROUGH -- TALKING ABOUT
LEARNING LAS AND WHAT STUDENTS
DEMONSTRATE MORE LEARNING
LAS THAN OTHERS -- YOU KNOW I
THINK EDUCATION WAS COMPLICATED
BEFORE AND CERTAINLY NOT
HAS NEVER BEEN AN EASY TASK
EDUCATORS OF PROFESSIONAL
WE'RE WE'RE READY TO DO THE JOB
EVEN EVEN THOUGH THEY HAD MANY
CHALLENGES AND -- YOU KNOW WHAT
WE USED TO SAY IN THE CLASSROOM
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER WAS THAT
WE'D NEVER HAD CONTROL OF WITH
THE CHILDREN CAME FROM THAT
THAT WAS OUT OF OUR CONTROL BUT
THAT WHAT WE DID HAVE CONTROL
AS WAS WHEN THE CHILDREN
CAME TO US AND CAME INTO OUR
CLASSROOM FOR THAT WHETHER IT
WAS FIFTY MINUTES FOR THAT PART
OF THE DAY OR FOR THAT DAY THE
TEACHER HAD CONTROL THAT IS
NO LONGER THE CASE -- ANYMORE
AT ALL OBVIOUSLY BUT I HEAR
YOU KNOW BOTH FROM STUDENTS
FROM PARENTS AND FROM TEACHERS
HOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WE WE YOU GAVE
US A VERY -- OVERVIEW RIGHT
BUT EDUCATION ALWAYS COMES
DOWN TO THE INDIVIDUALS AS
AS MR O'DONNELL SAID THE HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER WHO SAID THE
DISTANCE LEARNING SUCKS -- I
I HEAR FROM TEACHERS WHO ARE
TRYING THEIR HARDEST YOU KNOW
OF THAT FEEL THE FRUSTRATION
OF THE PARENTS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT OF THE INDIVIDUAL -- IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHO DOESN'T
HAVE ONE PLACE TO STAY WHO
DOESN'T HAVE ONE HOUSE TO STAY
AND AND AND IS MOVE BACK AND
FORTH FROM SEVERAL HOUSEHOLDS
OF MAY NOT HAVE HIS BOOK MAY
NOT HAS -- HIS LAPTOP AND
AND SO THE CHALLENGES ARE
TREMENDOUS AS MRS MISTRETTA
POINTED OUT -- I'M NOT SURE HOW
ANYONE IS -- GETTING THROUGH
WITH IT AT ALL -- I HAVE
GRANDCHILDREN IN SCHOOL AND I
HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO'S WORKING
AND AND AT THE SAME TIME HAVING
HER KIDS GOING TO SCHOOL SO
-- -- WITH MISTER O'DONNELL
AND THIS COMMITTEE TO SEE
HOW WE CAN MAKE THE SITUATION
BETTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL'S
TELLING EVERYBODY THAT IS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
FOR YOU BUT I JUST WANT TO READ
-- SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM MY
DISTRICT FROM PARENTS AND FROM
TEACHERS -- I RECEIVED NEARLY
A THOUSAND EMAILS FROM PARENTS
AND TEACHERS ACROSS SANTA
CLARITA AND SEAMY VALLEY AMID
DISTRICT I CAN'T WORK BECAUSE
I HAVE TO BE HOME WITH MY TEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING NOW I'M TAKING MONEY
FROM THE STATE IN THE FORM OF
UNEMPLOYMENT ACROSS THE STATE
SO MUCH MONEY MY DAUGHTER HAS
OCULAR HEADACHES AND NOW SEES
NEUROLOGISTS AT S.
C.
H.
L.
A.
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE OF THESE HEADACHES
NEXT COMMENT I TEACH ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN SCV THE STATE SCHOOLS
CLOSE ARE HURTING ALL STUDENTS
THEY NEED SOCIAL INTERACTION
IN PERSON EDUCATION DAILY
STRUCTURE THIS HAS TO STOP
NEXT COMMENT CHILD DEPRESSED
NO SOCIAL LIFE NO SPORTS NEXT
COMMENT MY SON'S PERSONALITY
HAS CHANGED FIFTH GRADER HE HAS
LOST HIS CONFIDENCE IN GENERAL
AND HATE SCHOOL MY NINTH GRADER
HAS NO HOPE OF GOING BACK AND
AT THIS POINT THEY JUST WANT
TO BE ABLE TO PLAY SOCCER
IN HIGH SCHOOL MY ONCE HAPPY
EAGER LEARNER HAS TURNED INTO
A TEARFUL ON MOTIVATED GRUMPY
KID WHO DRIED SCHOOL EACH DAY
IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO WATCH
OUR HEARTS ARE ALL BREAKING
FOR STUDENTS AT THIS VERY
MOMENT AND I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THESE NEEDS
BUT THESE ARE GOING TO BE SOME
LONG TERM NEEDS THAT WE HAVE
TO HAVE TO ADDRESS FOR FOR
OUR COMMUNITY SO MY QUESTIONS
THIRTY TO MOTIONAL HERE I
HEARD FROM MY COMMUNITY WHICH
ASPECTS OF DISTANCE LEARNING
HAVE BEEN MOST EFFECTIVE AND
SUPPORTING ACADEMIC INSTRUCTION
AS WELL AS A SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND WELL BEING
OF STUDENTS AND WHICH HAVE
BEEN THE MOST CHALLENGING
THIS IS HEATHER HOUSEHOLD ALL
JUMP IN FIRST WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF RESEARCH OVER IT SINCE
ESSENTIALLY THE PANDEMIC AND
MARCH TRYING TO GET A SENSE
OF THE RESEARCH BASE BEHIND
THIS QUESTION WHAT CAN WE DO
TO MAKE DISTANCE LEARNING WORK
FOR KIDS KNOWING THAT IT'S NOT
IDEAL AND IT CAN'T BE IDEAL BUT
A LOT OF WHAT MAKES DISTANCE
LEARNING WORK FOR CHILDREN IT'S
A LOT OF WHAT MAKES IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BURKE FOR CHILDREN
TOO IT'S THE MORE THAT YOU CAN
ENGAGE IN COLLABORATIVE WORK
THE MORE THAT STUDENTS CAN GET
FEEDBACK FROM THEIR TEACHER THE
MORE THAT THEY CAN WORK WITH
PEERS ON ISSUES OF LEARNED SO
WHEN DISTANCE LEARNING WORKS
FOR KIDS IT'S BECAUSE THERE'S
A STRUCTURE IN WHICH THERE
ARE MULTIPLE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING SMALL GROUP WORK WHO ARE
TRYING TO ENGAGE STUDENTS IN
A SIMILAR WAY TO HOW THEY WERE
ENGAGED BEFORE BUT I THINK
THE FACT TO THAT IS THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT THERE
REALLY ISN'T A GOOD ANALOG FOR
IN DISTANCE LEARNING THANK --
PHYSICAL EDUCATION IS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS RIGHT IT'S IT'S
REALLY EASY TO UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU CAN'T DO A SOCCER
GAME ON SECOND -- THERE ARE
LOTS OF SCIENCE EVENTS FOR
COLLABORATIVE WORK IT REALLY
IS DIFFICULT TO REPLICATE AND
ARE NOT SETTING SO AND THEN
OF COURSE YOU KNOW I I SPOKE
IN MY TESTIMONY ABOUT HOW EVEN
ACCESSING THINGS LIKE SMALL
GROUP WORK AND COLLABORATIVE
TIME OFTEN REQUIRE INTERNADO
AT HOME YOU CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THE STUDENT IS READY AND
ENGAGED IN LEARNING AND THAT
CAN BE A HUGE BARRIER -- BUT
BUT TYPICALLY THAT I THINK
WOULD BE WHAT MAKES DISTANCE
LEARNING COULD A PERSON
WHAT MAKES IT CHALLENGING
THANK YOU YEAH THANK YOU I
WILL I WOULD JUST ADD TO I
THINK AND I THINK OTHER RELATED
STRONG ENGAGEMENT IS ALWAYS
THE KEY RIGHTS CHILDREN HAVE
TO BE ENGAGED IN THEIR LEARNING
BUT IN ORDER TO FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN REALLY PARTICIPATE
AND THAT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE TO
FOCUS DISTANCE LEARNING WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING EDUCATORS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO IT OR REALLY
STRATEGIC IN A REALLY FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO PUT KIDS INTO YOUR
VARIOUS -- BREAKOUT GROUPS IN
PARTICULAR GIVING THEM SOME
PROJECTS TO DO OPPORTUNITIES
TO HAVE THE PEACE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS FOLKS ACTUALLY
REACHING OUT TO KIDS DIRECTLY
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
IS THE BABY MORE SUPPORTS
-- REACHING OUT TO PARENTS
IN TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
WORKING SPECIFICALLY STRATEGIES
IDEAS SO THEY CAN COLLECTIVELY
WORK TOGETHER BY HOW THEY
CAN SUPPORT THE STUDENT OUR
HISTORY LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT'S NOT THE
NORM THANKS BYE AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL STRUGGLE
WHERE THOSE EXAMPLES OF BEEN
ABLE TO HELP AND I THINK WE'LL
SEE MORE SUCCESS AND OBVIOUSLY
WE FOR THE OLDER STUDENTS AND I
SAY THE STUDENTS LIKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL ANGLER I AM
A SENIOR AT HOME BUT IT WAS
FAIRLY DISENGAGED BUT SHE'S
COMES NOT REALLY GOOD AT HOME
AND SHE'S SHE'S DOING FINE
BUT SHE'S NOT BECAUSE SHE'S
REALLY ENGAGED IN SCHOOL I'M
PARTICULAR BUT SHE'S BEEN OKAY
SHE'S GONNA BE ALRIGHT SHE'S
GONNA BE OK AND BE ABLE TO GO
ON SCHOOL RIGHT WERE IN SOME
OTHER FAMILIES THAT DON'T
HAVE THOSE TANK TYPE SPORTS
WHICH WE KNOW EXIST FOR A LOT
OF OUR CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK THANK
YOU AND ONE MORE QUESTION
-- WHAT DATA POINTS EXIST OR
WHAT POLICY JUST SUGGESTIONS
YOU HAVE AROUND REGRESSION
FOR SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
WE TALK ABOUT LEARNING LOSS
WHICH IS WHICH IS EVIDENT --
BUT THERE'S GOING TO BE SICK
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT REGRESSION
AND OUR CHILDREN DIAGNOSED
WITH AUTISM ON A CHILDREN
WITH OTHER DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS AND DISABILITIES --
WHAT ARE YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THE END OF ANY DATA
POINTS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
TO ADD TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE
HELLO THIS IS CARLA ESTRADA
WITH THE CCD ONE SUGGESTION
AS WE THINK ABOUT OUR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES WHO ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC IS TO REALLY
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO START
IDENTIFYING WHO THOSE STUDENTS
ARE WHAT SERVICES HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED WHAT HAS NOT AND
AS AS MR MOLINO HAS SHARED
ALSO REACHING OUT TO THOSE
FAMILIES TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
ARE THE AREAS THEY SEE THEIR
CHILDREN REGRESSING OR WHERE
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN REGRESSED
REGRESSION WE HAVE SEEN SOME
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO VERY WELL WITH CERTAIN
TYPES OF STRUCTURES OF DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT THERE ARE ALSO
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF KIDS WHO
HAVE NOT SO I THINK BEING ABLE
TO PRIORITIZE WHERE THE NEEDS
ARE SO PLANNING AND SUPPORTS
CAN START OCCURRING NOW IS
ONE OF THE FIRST STEPS THAT I
WOULD ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO DO
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH CD EVEN OTHER TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DO WE CONTINUE
TO HELP THEM PROBLEM SOLVE
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST HIGHEST
NEEDS STUDENTS -- DURING
DISTANCE LEARNING HOWEVER
WE'VE ALSO FOUND THAT ANOTHER
AREA FOR OUR DISTRICTS TO BE
ABLE TO PRIORITIZE PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES IS ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT OUR TEACHERS
AND THE WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
OF PROVIDERS AND HOW ARE THEY
WORKING TOGETHER AND THERE'S
BEEN SOME BRIGHT SPOTS THAT
WE'VE SEEN WHERE WHEN THOSE
WRAPAROUND TEAMS COME TOGETHER
AND REALLY PROBLEM SOLVE WHAT
IS WORKING FOR THESE CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES AND WHETHER
OR NOT THIS IS WHERE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SEE A GREATER
SUCCESS OF BEING ABLE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND SO
REALLY BEING ABLE TO BRING
THOSE PROVIDERS TOGETHER SO
THAT WAY THEY CAN WORK AROUND
BEING ABLE TO TO YOUR SUPPORT
REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
INTEGRATING THEIR SUPPORT
IN THE GENERAL EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE FOR YOUNG KIDS IS
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CLICK OKAY SEEING THAT
NUMBER QUESTIONS HERE I I DID
HAVE HAVE SOME BUT I I THINK
WE'LL JUST MOVE ON BUT NOTE
THAT -- THE POINTS THAT YOU
REYES ARE EXACTLY THE POINTS
THAT I KNOW THE ASSEMBLY IS
TRYING TO INCLUDE IN OUR RE
OPENING PLANTS ESPECIALLY WE
WE DEAL WITH WITH LEARNING LOST
REALIZING THAT IS GOING TO BE
AN ON GOING ASSESS SO WITH THAT
WE WILL BEGIN NOW WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE AND AGAIN WE'RE
GOING TO ONLY HEAR TWO ISSUES
TODAY ISSUE ONE IS THE DISTANCE
LEARNING IMPLEMENTATION
AND ISSUE TO THAT T.
K.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSALS AND WILL HOLD THE
OTHER ITEMS FOR ANOTHER HEARING
DATE SO -- OF COURSE THIS
IS A UNIQUE BUDGET PROCESS
HERE -- BUT THIS IS A UNIQUE
BUDGET TIME OF COURSE IS WITH
OUR SCHOOLS AND SO THIS PAST
YEAR OUR OUR BUDGET WE ADOPTED
LAST YEAR THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC BUDGET AUTHORIZED
STANDARDS FOR SCHOOLS IN
DURING SCHOOL CLOSURES TO
PREVENT A WILD WEST FOR -- OUR
SCHOOLS GOING FORWARD AND -- WE
REALIZE THAT THIS IS AN ONGOING
THING AND -- OUR DISTANCE
LEARNING LAWS GOING TO SUNSET
FORCING SCHOOLS -- -- -- TO
TAKE A REALITY CHECK ON WHAT
WE WANT TO DO GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE WE KNOW SUCH AS COVER
NINETEEN IT'S OTHER EMERGENCIES
LIKE WILDFIRES AND AND -- WE
SAW HERE WILL ANNOUNCE AND
SMOKE CLOSING OUR SCHOOLS IN
THE PAST AND SO THESE DISTANCE
LEARNING AND ZOOM EDUCATION
FRANKLY IS A USEFUL TOOL GOING
FORWARD BUT WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THE STANDARDS BUT
BEFORE THAT AGAIN -- WE WANT TO
TRY TO OPEN OUR SCHOOLS IN ANY
IMMEDIATE -- THAT TIME PERIOD
I DID NOTE EARLIER THAT WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THERE WOULD BE
-- AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION -- WE'RE STILL
IN NEGOTIATIONS WE DO HOPE
TO INTRODUCE A BILL IN THE
VERY NEAR FUTURE -- AND HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO VOTE ON
A PLAN TO REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS
THIS SPRING I DID WANT TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO COMMENT ON
THE FRAMEWORK OF OF OUR OF OUR
-- ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL THAT'S
BEEN WE HAVEN'T PUT IT IN PRINT
GET IT SHOULD BE IN PRINT AND
IN THE NEAR FUTURE -- BUT I
WILL JUST OUTLINED SOME OF
THE ELEMENTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ASK THEM IF THEY
WANTED TO RESPOND -- SO AGAIN
LET ME JUST GO OVER INSTEAD
A FEW BUCKETS HERE -- FOR THE
THE FUNDING PACKAGE ARE -- ARE
PLANNED WHICH WAS AGAIN THE
PLAN BRIEFLY OUTLINED WITH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE LEADERSHIP
THE SAFE OPEN IN SCHOOLS PLAN
-- WILL PROVIDE EDUCATION
SUPPORT THIS SPRING OF TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN RE OPENING
FUNDS FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
FOR LEARNING LOSS RECOVERY
AND SIX BILLION IN FEDERAL
REOPENING EIGHT FOR A TOTAL
OF TWELVE POINT SIX BILLION
AS FAR AS VACCINES -- THE PLAN
WOULD PUT ESSENTIAL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ON ON CAMPUS FIRST
IN LINE FOR THE STATE'S FAXING
DISTRIBUTIONS -- CALIFORNIA
WILL SET ASIDE A SIGNIFICANT
SHARE OF THE STATE'S VACCINE
ACCESS TO SUPPORT GETTING ALL
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES READY FOR
SAFE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AS
FAR AS OPENING -- THE THE THE
FRAMEWORK AND THE PLAN HAS
A SAFE AND OPEN SCHOOLS RE
OPENING OF APRIL THE FIFTEENTH
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR MINIMUM
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL
SCHOOLS ARE BEGINNING APRIL
FIFTEENTH THE PLAN FOCUSES
ON ALL SCHOOLS MUST OFFER IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION IN STABLE
COURTS TO CATER TWELVE STUDENTS
THAT CHRONICALLY ABSENT FROM
SCHOOL WITHOUT ACCESS TO
DISTANCE LEARNING AS WELL AS
INCLUDING OTHER VULNERABLE
STUDENTS INCLUDING HOMELESS
AT RISK FOR ABUSE FOSTER YOUTH
IN STRUGGLING ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS -- ALL SCHOOLS IN
COUNTIES IN THE RED TIER BETTER
WITH LESS THAN EIGHT CASES
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND THE READ
HERE -- MUST OFFER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION TO ALL K.
THREE SIX STUDENTS AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE COHORT STUDENTS
-- AGAIN ALL SCHOOLS MUST
ALLOW FAMILIES TO CHOOSE
PARENTS CHOICE FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING FOR THEIR STUDENTS
OR IN PERSON AND REGARDLESS
OF FUNDING WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
HAVING ALL SCHOOLS MUST ADOPT
COVERT SAFETY PLANS -- MEETING
CITY PH GUIDANCE FOR SAFETY
AND TESTING -- IF THE SCHOOL
IS UNABLE TO MEET THIS PHASE
THREE OPENING -- THEY WOULD
FORFEIT THEIR SHARE OF THE
STATE'S TWO BILLION RE OPENING
SUPPORT AND -- IN MAY FACED
-- FURTHER ACTIONS IF THEY
HAVE NOT ADOPTED TO SAY FREE
OPENING PLAN UP TO OR SCHOOLS
THAT ALREADY HAVE REOPENED
I KNOW THAT MR GALLAGHER IS
ASKED THIS QUESTION IN PARTS
OF THE STATE WE HAVE ALREADY
REOPENED THAT THEY MAY PROCEED
WITH THEIR PLANS THEIR PLANS
OF COURSE ALREADY HAVE FOCUSING
ON STRICT DISTANCING TESTING
A MASKING AND OTHER MEANT AND
OTHER -- SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
-- AND THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
THE FACT IT AGAIN KATE SIX
THREE SCHOOLS ARE ALLOWED
TO OPEN ONCE -- THEIR CASES
DROP BELOW -- TWENTY FIVE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS
IN THEIR COUNTY REGARDLESS
OF THEIR FUNDING -- GROUP
REGARDLESS OF THE STATE
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS WE'RE
JUST REOPENING AGAIN THE RED
TIER AND SO -- I KNOW WE ARE
CURRENT -- HOPEFUL NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY IN ADMINISTRATION
LEADERSHIP ONE ASKED A PART
IN A FINANCE TO A PINE ON THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE JUST OUTLINED
GOOD EVENING LIMóN MCCARTY ARE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME OKAY YES
GREAT THIS IS AMBER ALEXANDER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
-- THE ADMINISTRATION AND
ALIGNMENT WITH THE -- FEDERAL
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION DOES CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO SAFELY REOPEN SCHOOLS
NOW -- AND WE AGREE WITH YOU
THAT IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
IS ESSENTIAL AND TO BACK HIM
SIX OF OUR STUDENTS ALL THAT
BEING SAID -- I I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU PROVIDED A DETAILED
-- OVERVIEW OF THE PROVISIONS
OF THE PROPOSAL AND WE HAVE
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
THOSE IN ANY DEPTH AND AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION -- ON THE FRAMEWORK
THAT YOU HAVE LAID OUT
OKAY I'M MISTER MISTER
O'DONNELL I I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT MR MCCARTY WHAT YOU
BROUGHT UP IN THE PROPOSAL
WAS A PLAN TO VACCINATE
TEACHERS WHICH I THINK IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR THE SAFETY OF
TEACHERS YES THE SAFETY OF
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS BUT ALSO
THE SAFETY OF THE STUDENTS IN
THE CLASSROOM SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND THEY SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY SO THANK YOU YEAH I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WELL FIRST OF ALL I KNOW WE'RE
PUTTING YOU IN A TOUGH SPOT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT
-- WE ARE GOING OVER THESE
ELEMENTS LINE BY LINE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION MAYBE NOT
YOU PERSONALLY AND -- LET'S
FACE IT AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VITAS READ HER STATEMENTS
FROM HER CONSTITUENTS ALL
EIGHTY OF US IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND FRANKLY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
ONE FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES -- YOU KNOW
YOU CAN GET THE ECONOMY GOING
BACK UNLESS WE FOCUS ON OUR
SCHOOLS AND -- I I THINK THAT
WERE IN A IN A GOOD PLACE I
SEE JUST ANNOUNCEMENT JUST
THIS AFTERNOON FOR MARK MY
PRESIDENT SAYING THAT -- THE
WEEKLY SHIPMENTS TO ST STE IS
NOW -- YOU KNOW OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION DOSES PER WEEK AND THAT
THE RULE OF THUMB OF COURSE IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE GET ABOUT
TEN PERCENT OF WHATEVER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S PUTTING
OUT SO THAT'S OVER A MILLION
DOSES FOR CALIFORNIA -- AND
DOWNWARD WE'RE DOING OVER A
MILLION A WEEK SO WE'RE WE'RE
WELL ON OUR WAY TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR ALL
EDUCATORS TO GET OUT OF EXTEND
NO HERE IN SACRAMENTO OUR CAR
COUNTY -- -- SCHOOL SYSTEM IS
PUTTING OUT THE WORD THAT WILL
BE HAVING THAT IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE AS WELL SO I THINK
THAT NOT ONLY AT THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE PUTTING ON THE TABLE TO
INCENTIVIZE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WERE HEARING EDUCATORS TALKING
ABOUT THE VACCINE IS A KEY
PIECE OF THE PIECE OF IT AS
WELL -- BUT -- WE WOULD ASK
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION YOU
KNOW WORK WITH US WE HAVE --
WE THINK AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE TWO HOUSES ON RE OPENING
OUR SCHOOLS AND WE'RE VERY
SERIOUS ABOUT PUTTING A BILL
UP FOR A VOTE IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE SO -- YOU KNOW WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE UPON
AND WE CERTAINLY -- APPRECIATE
THE COLLABORATION THAT
HAS OCCURRED -- AROUND THE
SCHOOL OPENING PROPOSAL AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR WITH
YOUR TV OKAY AND I I THIS IS
KIND OF CHOPPY HERE OF COURSE
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM FROM FROM -- YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS FAR
AS THE -- DISTANCE LEARNING
IMPLEMENTATION WITH -- THAT
THAT THAT PLAN SUNSETTING THIS
YEAR AND FOCUSING ON GOING FOR
ITSELF WELL NOW YOU TO TALK
ABOUT THE SPLIT SECOND BUDGET
-- OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME SEEING NONE SO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE LET'S GET BACK TO
THE REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS
AND ALLOW YOU TO PRESENT ON
THIS ITEM IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR TERROR -- AGAIN AMBER
ALEXANDER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I'LL BE PROVIDING
A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS AROUND
DISTANCE LEARNING THAT WERE
PUT INTO PLACE IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT -- AS WELL
AS BE ACCOMPANIED TRAILER
BILL AND DISTANCE LEARNING IS
DEFINED IN STATUTE AS -- IN
OUR INSTRUCTION IN WHICH THE
STUDENT AND INSTRUCTOR ARE IN
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS -- THAT WAS
IT AND THEIR GENERAL DEFINITION
-- AND THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE
-- AS PART OF THE NEGOTIATIONS
SAME COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS
THAT TOOK PLACE LAST YEAR OVER
THE SUMMER AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA BUT TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT -- EXPRESSED THE INTENT
BUT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
OFFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO
THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
WHILE ALSO ALLOWING THEM TO
OFFER THIS DISTANCE LEARNING
OPTION AND OR HYBRID MODELS
OF LEARNING UNDER CONDITIONS
AND CIRCUMSTANCES DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL
YEAR THE AGENDA -- DOESN'T
I STRUGGLE PLAYING OUT A
LOT OF THE PROVISIONS AND HE
COMPLIMENTS AROUND DISTANCE
LEARNING AND THOSE CAN BE FOUND
ON PAGES THREE AND FOUR -- ALSO
ON PAGE FOUR THE AGENDA LAYS
OUT SEVERAL OF THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE AIMED AT ENSURING THAT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
MAINTAINING REGULAR CONTACT
WITH STUDENTS FOR PARTICIPATING
AND DISTANCE LEARNING AND --
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
NOT REITERATE THOSE PERFECT
PROVISIONS BUT AGAIN HE JUST
GREEN PARTY AGENDA ASSEMBLY
THOSE OUT SINCE THESE DISTANCE
LEARNING PROVISIONS WERE PUT IN
PLACE THIS PAST SUMMER BINANCE
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
LEGISLATIVE STAFF FROM BOTH
HOUSES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I HAVE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE -- IN ORDER
TO BETTER ASSIST IN DEVELOPED
GUIDANCE FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WHO ARE ADAPTING TO
THIS DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL
-- MUCH OF THIS GUIDANCE CAN
BE FOUND ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION'S WEBSITE IN
THE FORM OF AND I THINK USE
IN ADDITION TO THAT DISTANCE
LEARNING STATUTES THEMSELVES
BUT TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY BUDGET
ACT INCLUDED SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DISTANCE
LEARNING CURRICULUM GUIDANCE
THAT'S BASED ON THE STATE'S
COMMON CORE STANDARDS IN MATH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION -- HAVE BEEN SELECTED
TO CARRY OUT THIS WORK AND THEY
HAVE PARTNERED WITH THE SOCIETY
FOR TECHNOLOGY IN EDUCATION
-- AS WELL AS CURRICULUM
EXPERTS AT BOTH STANFORD IN
THE CSU SYSTEM TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE THAT'LL HELP TEACHERS
IMPROVE REMOTE LEARNING AND
LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY -- THIS
DISTANCE LEARNING CURRICULUM
GUIDANCE IS EXPECTED TO GO
BEFORE THE BOARD AND BY THAT
BY THE MAIN BOARD MEETING
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
NEED TO CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS IN ADDRESSING
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN FACING I'M PARTICULARLY
OVER THIS PAST YEAR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAKEHOLDERS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH OUR SPRING PROCESS AND
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS AROUND
AND DISTANCE LEARNING AND WHAT
SCHOOL MAY LOOK LIKE IN THE
FALL WHEN WE RE OPEN I'M FOR
THAT MODEL I HAVE WITH ME AND
MY COLLEAGUE ERIN FOR RADIO --
ALSO REMOTE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER AND ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
NOW OR IF IT'S A DIFFERENT TIME
IS MORE APPROPRIATE THAT IS
FINE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
WE CAN PROCEED TO L.
L.
AND WE CAN COME BACK TO
THE DIFFERENT OTHER FINANCE
REPRESENT IF WE HAVE QUESTIONS
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS IN
THE LEAD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO ALTHOUGH
THE BUDGET ASKING THE SCHOOL
WHO RETURNED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION FOR THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR
AND DOES NOT EXTEND PROVISIONS
RELATED TO DISTANCE LEARNING
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER ALLOWING
DISTANCE LEARNING UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY STILL BE
WARRANTED OUR OFFICE DOESN'T
HAVE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME KEY
QUESTIONS THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER ON THIS
ISSUE GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTIES
OVER HOW THAT PANDEMIC NAY
PROGRESS OVER THE NEXT YEAR
THE LEGISLATURE ME WANTS
TO INCLUDE CONTINGENCIES
THAT ALLOW FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING UNDER SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS FOR INSTANCE THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO ALLOW
STUDENTS OR FAMILIES WITH
MEDICAL CONDITIONS MAY BE
PARTICULARLY AT RISK FOR KOBE
NINETEEN TO HAVE THE OPTION
OF CONTINUING UNDER DISTANCE
LEARNING ALTERNATIVELY THESE
POSSIBILITIES MAY ASSIST
THE STATE IN RESPONDING
TO MORE LONG STANDING
CHALLENGES RELATED TO NATURAL
DISASTERS SUCH AS WILDFIRES
OR EARTHQUAKES RATHER THAN
AFFECTED STUDENTS LOSING THE
REMAINDER OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
WHEN A NATURAL DISASTER OCCURS
WHICH OFTENTIMES HAPPENS THE
STUDENT COULD INSTEAD CONTINUE
TO ACCESS EDUCATION THROUGH
DISTANCE LEARNING WELL THE
COMMUNITY RESPONSE AND REBELS
SECONDLY IF SOME FORM OF REMOTE
LEARNING FORTY CONTINUE THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT
TO CONSIDER ANY ADDITIONAL
CHANGES TO DISTANCE LEARNING
AN INDEPENDENT STUDY TO BETTER
SUPPORT STUDENT LEARNING THIS
WOULD ENTAIL REVISITING THEIR
REQUIREMENTS CURRENTLY IN PLACE
AND EVALUATING WHETHER SUCH
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE EXTENDED
MODIFIED OR ALLOWED TO EXPIRE
AND THEN CONSIDERING WHETHER
ANY ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
SHOULD BE PUT IN PLACE ON THIS
NOTE THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER DISTANCE LEARNING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ALTHOUGH
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO SUPPORT FOR
A SCHOOL DASHBOARD FOR KOBE
NINETEEN AND HIS EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE THE LEGISLATURE ME ONE
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
SPECIFIC TO DISTANCE LEARNING
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET TO ENSURE INSTRUCTION
IS CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
INTENT WITH THAT I WILL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS BUT HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
PERFECT TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
GOOD EVENING ALLEN GARNER
ON THE HAVE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION IT NOT SPEAK
STERNER CHALLENGES STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS HAVE
FACED AND CONTINUE TO FACE
IN DISTANCE LEARNING WE HAVE
NEVER EXPERIENCED THIS KIND
OF TECTONIC SHIFT IN THE WAY
EDUCATION OUR OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM FUNCTIONS AND MUCH
OF WHAT WE FACE THIS LAST
YEAR HAS BEEN REALLY TRULY
UNCHARTED TERRITORY THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS HAS ALWAYS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE OUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY WHEN HEALTH
OFFICIALS SAY IT'S UNSAFE FOR
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS TO TAP
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION DISTANCE
LEARNING HAS PROVIDED THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION TO OUR STUDENTS BUT
THIS TRANSITION HAS HAD ITS
CHALLENGES LET'S BASIC SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA WAS NEVER MEANT
TO BE TAUGHT THIS WAY WE ARE
WORKING ON GETTING DEVICES
FOR OUR SIX POINT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS TO SUPPORT AND TRAIN
TEACHERS TO TEACH IN THIS NEW
ENVIRONMENT TO FIND WAYS TO
KEEP OUR STUDENTS ENGAGED AND
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
HAVE THE MENTAL AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT TO GET THEM
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC DISTANCE
LEARNING WILL LIKELY BE WITH
US IN SOME FORM MOVING FORWARD
EVEN AS SCHOOLS ARE ALLOWED TO
REOPEN IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
WE'VE SEEN EACH COMMITTED TO
OFFERING REAL TIME ACTIONABLE
SUPPORT FOR EDUCATORS AS WE
LEAN INTO THIS NEW REALITY AS
APARTMENT OF FINANCE IN LA ARE
DISCUSSED THE STANDARDS AND
THE STORY FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
WILL SUNSET IN JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ABSENT A LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE THE INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME LAWS AND STATUTES THAT
GOVERN GOVERNMENT DEGENERATION
OF ATTENDANCE PROPORTIONATE
EXISTED PRIOR TO COVER NINETEEN
WILL BE BACK IN A FACT BASED
ON CURRENT LAW ALL AT LEAST
NEED TO FOLLOW INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME AND ATTENDANCE ACCOUNTING
ONCE IN PLACE PRIOR TO DISTANCE
LEARNING ABSENT A LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE THE DISTANCE LEARNING
ANNOUNCES THAT WERE THAT
WERE CREATED WILL EXPIRE
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS ALL
STUDENTS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
MUST BE OFFERED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THAT MEETS CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THIS INCLUDES THE
ANNUAL MINUTE REQUIREMENT THE
ANNUAL NUMBER OF SCHOOL THE
REQUIREMENT AND THE MINIMUM
DAY REQUIREMENT STUDENTS MUST
BE SCHEDULED FOR THE MINIMUM
DAY AND TO THE EXTENT TO
DISTRICT OFFERS INDEPENDENT
STUDY STUDENTS CAN OPT TO
PARTICIPATE IN INDEPENDENCE
ATTY ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS AS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO ATTENDING
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IT IS
LIKELY THAT TEAMS WOULD NEED
TO BE MADE TO THE LINE TO
MAKE THIS PROGRAM FEASIBLE
ON A DISTRICT OR STUDENTS
MIGHT BE SAYS THEY'RE ALSO
NOTES ABOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND CO USE AS FAR AS THEIR
REQUIREMENTS FOR SPORT IN
PERSON LEARNING THAT WILL
BE REINSTATED START TO START
ALSO PROVIDES PROTECTIONS TO
A LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY IF IT
IS UNABLE TO THE INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME REQUIREMENTS OR EXPERIENCE
MATERIAL LAST ATTENDANCE DUE
TO AN EMERGENCY WHILE THESE
UNLOCK LAS INSURANCE ONLY A
WILL BE HELD HARMLESS DUE TO
ANY FUNDING LOSS DUE TO SCHOOL
CLOSURE OR LOSS OF ATTENDANCE
IN THE CASE NUMBER AGENCY IT
DOES NOT PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
A LOST INSTRUCTIONAL TIME THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT I
HAVE WITH ME REGIONAL NEEDS
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
INSTRUCTION AND MEASUREMENT
BRANCH CVT FOR PROGRAMMATIC
QUESTIONS AND WANTING TO
CANCEL WHO IS THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR CURRENT SCHOOL
PHYSICAL SERVICE DIVISION TO
ANSWER ANY FISCAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT DISTANCE LEARNING
QUESTIONS MISTER DONNA YES
SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I APPRECIATE THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE THAT THERE MAY
BE A PLACE WILL THERE IS A
PLACE GOING FORWARD FOR SOME
ONLINE LEARNING I THINK ON A
VERY LIMITED BASIS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO FIND SUCCESS
WITH ONLINE LEARNING I THINK
IT'S BEEN MINIMAL THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE BUT I THINK AGAIN
THERE IS A PLACE BOB BUT WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL WITH THAT
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE IS PEOPLE
WITH NO ETHICS NO DESIRE TO
ENSURE STUDENT SUCCESS YET A
DESIRE TO BECOME A MILLIONAIRE
THAT HAVE GONE IN TO THE ONLINE
CHARTER SCHOOL BUSINESS MADE
TONS OF MONEY AND NOT SERVE
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL WHEN YOU TO REFORM IT
IS TO BE SIGNIFICANT REFORM
WITH THE -- THE ONLINE CHARTER
SCHOOL VENTURES THAT WE NOW
HAVE AN ANY THAT MAY COME
FORWARD AFTER THE MORATORIUM
IN WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE AND
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THIS
HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ONLY AS TO TO ENTER
THIS VENTURE BECAUSE THEY'RE
PROBABLY BETTER PREPARED ON
THE ACADEMIC SIDE AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SIDE THAN
SOMEONE WHO JUST OPENED UP A
SCHOOL OVERNIGHT SAYS GUESS
WHAT I AM PUTS ONLINE AND --
MY COMMIT FRAUD MIGHT NOT THE
WAVE JUST YOU KNOW GOOGLE YAHOO
IT IT'LL COME UP -- HOW MANY
CASES THERE HAVE BEEN A FRAUD
OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE NOT
SERVE STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO AGAIN I'M LOOKING
FOR THIS INCIDENT SIGNIFICANT
REFORM TO ENSURE STUDENT
SUCCESS -- IS A PRIORITY WHEN
WITH ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOLS
GOING FORWARD BE THE CHARTER
OR NOT QUITE FRANKLY BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU RECOGNIZE
THERE MAY BE A PLACE FOR THIS
TYPE OF LEARNING AND AND AND
YOU KNOW I DO RECOGNIZE THAT
BUT AGAIN THERE'S A HARLEY
THERE NEEDS TO BE SIGNIFICANT
REFORM WITH THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CURRENTLY PERFORMANCE
OR THAT SEEK TO DO IT IN THE
FUTURE OF ANY TYPE WITH THAT
BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU THANK YOU I DO HAVE A
QUESTION BUT I'LL JUST NOTE
-- MISTER DONALD THAT AS
YOU KNOW WE PASSED A LAW --
THAT WE YOU AND I WORKED ON
TOGETHER WHICH IS OUTLAWED --
THESE FOR PROFIT -- ONLINE --
CHARTERS BUT YOU WERE G.
OF BILKING TAXPAYERS AND
HAD MASSIVE JUDGMENTS BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
FRAUDULENT PRACTICES -- BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE AREN'T
OTHERS WHO ARE NOT FOR PROFIT
THEY COULD GET IN THIS BUSINESS
SO WE MAKE SURE WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT FRONT
AS WELL SO THERE IS A PLACE
FOR FOR ONLINE I THINK WE'VE
LEARNED THAT WE ALSO LEARNED
THAT WE HAVE OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT THAT MAY HAPPEN
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW GOD FORBID THAT WE
HAVE YOU KNOW WERE ICED OVER
LIKE WE SEE IT IN TEXAS RIGHT
NOW WITH THOSE STUDENTS ARE OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR A WEEK OR MORE
AND HAVING THAT ONLINE DISTANCE
-- PROGRAM FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I THINK IS VALUABLE IN THE FACT
WE HAVE HAD A NATURAL DISASTERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THE STUDENTS
CONTINUE TO LEARN SO WITH THAT
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I KNOW
THERE ARE IN THE CHEN ALREADY
BUT ALL AT ALASKA EITHER
EDUCATION OR ANYBODY ELSE AS
FAR AS -- WE WENT THROUGH THIS
THE PAST ROUGHLY YEAR AND SO
WE DID HAVE THESE DISTANCE
LEARNING STANDARDS AND POLICIES
SO WHICH ONES DO WE THINK NEED
CLARIFICATION -- STRENGTHENING
-- IF WE WERE CONTINUE THIS
IN THE NEXT YEAR OR FRANKLY
HAVING DISTANCE LEARNING PLANS
REGARDLESS OF CLUB IN NINETEEN
SO LET'S START WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
MISTER CHAIR -- AMBER ALEXANDER
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I KNOW -- AND STATED IN MY
OPENING REMARKS -- AFTER THAT
LANGUAGE WAS RELEASED LAST
SUMMER AROUND DISTANCE LEARNING
WE DID GO THROUGH A PROCESS
AND WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND LEGISLATIVE STOP
IN STATE COURT WHERE WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE COMING IN FROM THE
FIELD AND TRYING TO -- PROVIDE
SOME GUIDANCE AND GET AHEAD
OF -- YOU KNOW SOME ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT MAY BE BE
STEMMING -- AROUND DISTANCE
LEARNING PROVISIONS THAT WE
WILL OFFER A SIMILAR PROCESS
RECOGNIZING THAT DISTANCE
LEARNING -- IN THE YOU KNOW IN
RESPONSE TO PANDEMIC ON MAY BE
DIFFERENT -- THEN THE DISTANCE
LEARNING WE'RE ENVISIONING
AROUND CIRCUMSTANCES RELATED TO
WILDFIRE OR OTHER EMERGENCIES
THAT MAY MAY NOT BE QUITE AS
LONG TERM -- I DON'T KNOW IF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAS -- ANY ANY MORE INSIGHTS TO
PROVIDE BUT I THINK THAT WOULD
BE OUR COMMENTS ON THE QUESTION
DOES THE L.
A.
O.
HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS
ELLY AT EMILY WITH THE L.
A.
L.
AT THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUGGESTIONS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BY ABOUT US
I'M HOW IS THE OTHER GUY GOING
TO EXAMINE WHETHER ELEAZAR
OFFERED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE AS REQUIRED BY THE
STATUTE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I THINK WE WOULD DEFER THAT
QUESTION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION -- WILL ENHANCE
THAT CERTAIN AUTOCRATIC
MEETINGS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION HAS NOT BEEN
WORKING MOST CLOSELY WITH
THE CONTROLLER AND CONVENING
THOSE CLASSIC AYE SESSIONS
GOOD EVENING ELLIE GARNER
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION THE TEAMS TO
THE AUDIT GUIDE SUPPLEMENT
PROCEDURES FOR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS A RESULT
IN DISTANCE LEARNING ONLY
INCLUDE THOSE ELEMENTS
THERE SPECIFICALLY CALLED
OUT IN STATUTE AS HAVING
FINANCIAL COUNT PENALTIES
FOR GOING ON MATT WELL IT
THE REQUIREMENT THAT OFFER
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO
THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
THERE'S NOT A SPECIFIC PENALTY
OR CONDITION OF A PORTION OF
THAT PROVISION WE WOULD LIKE
TO EDUCATION CODE SECTION ONE
FOUR FIVE OH TWO POINT ONE
THAT SPECIFIES THAT IN ORDER
TO BE INCLUDED IN AN IPOD
SUPPLEMENT AND I'LL AN ELEMENT
WOULD NEED TO BE A CONDITION
OF APPORTIONMENT AND THAT
EDUCATION CODE SECTION FOUR
THREE FIVE OH FOUR INDICATES
WHICH DISTANCE LEARNING
ELEMENTS CARRY FINANCIAL
PENALTY FOR GOING ON THAT
OKAY THANK YOU
THIS IS ME THIS IS AN ACTION
THAT WE DON'T HAVE I RECOMMEND
ACTION TONIGHT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- WE WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE YOUR BACK IN THE
MAY REVISE AND ADDRESSES LATER
IN THE YEAR THANK YOU WITHOUT
PROCEED TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
SO LET'S CUE UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE L.
AGAIN I'M THIS IS THE ISSUE
RELATED TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND AGAIN JUST
FOR THE PUBLIC THIS IS THE
LAST ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO BE
HERE TONIGHT WE'RE GONNA HOLD
UP BUT THE OTHER ISSUES TO
TO ANOTHER DATE AB THIS ISSUE
WE'RE HEARING AGAIN IS RELATED
TO THE GOVERNOR'S TKA PROPOSALS
AND THE JANUARY BUDGET AS WE
KNOW PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
AND LIAISE IN THE EXPANSION
OF UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN -- THIS IS A
KEY MOMENT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
UC SYSTEM AND OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS WE KNOW THE GOVERNOR
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF A
ROBUST PLANNED TO LOOK AT EARLY
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS NOT THE END ALL BUT ONE
ELEMENT AS FAR AS HOW WE CAN
BRING ABOUT UNIVERSAL ACCESS
FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS AND THE THAT
THE NOTION WAS IF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE UNIVERSAL PRE K.
IN CALIFORNIA FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS LIKE MANY STATES
TO EXPANDING OUR EXISTING
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
SYSTEM IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE -- ROUTE TO GO --
WE DO HAVE THE L.
A.
O.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HERE
TO TALK TO US AND AND AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT --
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN
AND THE ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION HAD FOCUSED ON THESE
ISSUES THAT NOT JUST ONE IT'S
A FEW THINGS -- A FOCUS ON
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
VOLUNTARILY EXPAND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN NOW AS WE FOCUSING
ON HIGH UNIVERSAL FOR EVERYBODY
OVER THE NEXT DECADE ALSO WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
HELP STABILIZE OUR CHILD CARE
SYSTEM THROUGH ADEQUATE FUNDING
WHICH WE WILL TALK ABOUT
A COUPLE WEEKS N.
AS WELL AS MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE A FLEXIBLE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS THE NEEDS
OF WORKING PARENTS INCLUDING
FULL DAY FULL YEAR AND WRAP IN
THE EARLIER GRADES LIKE T.
K.
LIKE WE SEE IN IS NEEDED RIGHT
NOW FOR OUR KINDERGARTENERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ELIADE CD TO GO OVER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR UNIVERSAL T.
K.
IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING ON
THE SERVER OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES RIGHT SO YES I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR A
COMPETITIVE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT PROGRAM TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF HIGHLY QUALIFIED
TEACHERS AVAILABLE TO SERVE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
STUDENTS GRANT FUNDING CAN
BE USED FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES OF
CURRENT TJ AND KINDERGARTEN
TEACHERS TO SUPPORT THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD INSTRUCTION FOR
CHILD DEVELOPMENT THE BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO TV PROGRAMS
THE GRANT FUNDING CAN BE USED
FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
CREATING OR EXPANDING SHE CAME
PROGRAMS AND IT WILL BE AWARDED
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS FOR THE
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL FOUR YEAR
OLDS AND ELLIE PROPOSES TO
SERVE IN ITS GRANT APPLICATION
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO CONSTRUCT AND RETROFIT
EXISTING FACILITIES TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
IN FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
WITH THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
INCREASED ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES FOR T.
K.
AS WELL AS FULL DAY EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I'M JOINED
HERE BY A FEW OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU L.
L.
SARAH CORTEZ LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO WE HAVE
A FEW COMMENTS REGARDING
THE GOVERNOR'S TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PER CLICK ON
PACKAGE I'M SO FIRST WHEN DID
YOU KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS HAD A PRIOR INTEREST IN
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION HOWEVER
IN MOST RECENT YEARS THE STATE
HAS DONE A PRESCHOOL EXPANSION
THROUGH THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM SO WHETHER T.
CARE STATE PRESCHOOL THE
BEST OPTION TO EXPAND REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE LEGISLATURE'S
GOALS FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO OFFER
WHEN YOU'RE A PUBLIC PRESCHOOL
TO ALL STUDENTS THEN HE COULD
BE A BETTER PATH TO EXPANSION
THE STATE COULD YOU SCHOOL
DISTRICT CATCHMENT AREAS AS A
WAY TO ENSURE THAT ALL ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN WILL HAVE ACCESS TO TO
KEEP PROGRAM IF THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO OFFER PRESCHOOL TO
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THEN THIS
A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM COULD BE
ABOUT A PATH TO EXPANSION TO
PRESCHOOL ALREADY SERVES A
LARGE NUMBER OF STUDENTS FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE SECOND WE KNOW THAT
HE CAN EXPANSION REQUIRED
ONGOING FUNDING WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS
INCLUDES ONE TIME FUNDING
-- WELL THERE ARE SOME ONE
TIME COSTS OF JUST DISABILITY
CONSTRUCTION UPDATE THEIR
ONGOING COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
SERVING ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
SUCH AS HIRING ADDITIONAL
TEACHERS THIRD WE ESTIMATE THE
STATE COULD SUSTAIN ONGOING
COSTS OF EXPANDING TKA WITHIN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SPECIFICALLY WERE REFERRING
TO IF THE STATE ALLOWED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO GENERATE
A FULL YEAR OF ATTENDANCE
BASED FUNDING FOR CHILDREN
WITH FOR DAYS AFTER DECEMBER
SECOND HOWEVER WE WOULD DO
-- HOWEVER THIS WILL LIMIT
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO MAKE
MAJOR ONGOING PROGRAMMATIC
CAPABLE OF MUTATIONS OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS LASTLY WE
WOULD NOTE THAT T.
HE EXPANSION IF SUCCESSFUL
WOULD HAVE A SIZEABLE IMPACT
ON STATE PRESCHOOL GOLDMINT
ALTHOUGH THE PROGRAM CONSERVE
YOUNGER STUDENTS ROUGHLY
SIXTY THREE PERCENT OF PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS ARE FOR YOUR WAS
FOUR YEARS OLD CLARIFYING THE
ROLE OF THE PRESCHOOL WOULD
ENSURE THE STATE'S EXISTING
PROGRAMS OPERATE IN ALIGNMENT
TO BEST SERVE CHILDREN OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THANK YOU
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME OKAY THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THANK YOU HONORING THE
HAVE THE STATE'S DIFFERENT
HAS THE PUBLIC INSPECTION
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN THE S.
S.
P.
I FULLY SUPPORT THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM AND WE ARE PLEASED TO
SEE THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FOR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
IN BOTH FACILITIES AND TEACHER
TRAINING WITH THAT I HAVE WITH
ME IS THERE ANOTHER MORGAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT STV'S
MEDICINAL COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THERE NEVER MARK
AND DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TURNING THURMAN'S
BEFORE GIVING HER COMMENTS ON
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS WITHIN
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR T.
K.
I WANTED TO START BY JUST A
FEW KEY OVER THE YEARS AND
WHAT ARE STATE PRESCHOOL SYSTEM
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM WHICH WAS MENTIONED
AS WELL AS TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN OBERNOLTE CASERT
JUST OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
WHERE THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR REGULAR TWO K.
WITH BIRTHDAYS BETWEEN
SEPTEMBER SECOND AND DECEMBER
SECOND AND NEARLY SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND WHO ACCESSED THE
EARLY ADMITTANCE R.
ET QUE WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE
BIRTHDAYS BETWEEN DECEMBER
SECOND AND THE END OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
NINE PERCENT OF THOSE CHILDREN
WERE SERVED IN TWO K.
QUALIFY FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS IT CAN'T HURT TO
SHOW THE OTHER SIDE INSKEEP
PETE STARK ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND CHILDREN FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WITH ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THOSE
BEING BROWN AND THREE YEAR
OLDS AND SEVENTY ONE PERCENT
THAT SB SIX THOUSAND BEING FOR
AND REDUCED MEALS OVER EIGHTY
PERCENT ARE FROM FAMILIES
WITH INCOMES BELOW THE GREEN
RETAIN THIS PRICE NOW SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ARE ALLOWED BUT NOT
REQUIRED TO OFFER EACH U.
K.
TO CHILDREN WHO HAVE THOSE
BIRTHDAYS BETWEEN DECEMBER
SECOND AND THE END OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR BUT THEY ONLY
RECEIVED FINES AND FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AFTER THEY TURN FIVE
THERE ALSO IS A PROVISIONAL LAW
THAT ALLOWS FOR NEXT YES K.
STERN'S WHICH ALLOWS DISTRICTS
TO SERVE CHILDREN IN S.
YES HE ENTERED THEIR
FIFTH BIRTHDAY AND THEN
THEY TRANSITION TO T.
K.
SO THAT BASICALLY THE CLASSROOM
HAS LAYERED FUNDING WITHOUT
MINE I'M GONNA DIVE INTO
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
INCENTIVE GRANT BUT DISTRICTS
TO EXPAND ACCESS FOR EACH U.
K.
OVERALL BUSINESS GARNER SHARED
WE ARE REALLY PLEASED TO
SEE THE PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN EXPANDING ACCESS TO THE
GARDEN PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
AND GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR SUPPORTING
US WE KNOW FROM THE RESEARCH
THAT ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS IS
ESSENTIAL TO REDUCING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IMPROVING
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
ADDRESSING THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE AND ADDRESSING
SYSTEMIC INEQUALITIES AND
RACIAL DISPARITIES WE ARE ALSO
PLEASED TO SEE THE PARTY FORGET
THE GUESTS AND SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS THAT EXPAND ACCESS
OR DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
FULL DAY PROGRAMS INCLUSIVE
PROGRAM SO THAT CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES OUR IN THE SCENE
ASTROS SETTING AS THEIR PEERS
AND AREAS WHERE THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT DISPROPORTIONATELY
PARTICULAR RACES OR ETHNICITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION AS PROPOSAL
MOVES FORWARD REALLY WANNA
ELEVATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ALIGNING WITH THE MASTER PLAN'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND HAVING
A STRONG MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM
WHICH INCLUDES THE STP IN
PARTICULAR WE LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
AND ADDRESS HE CAN'T QUALITY
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE
TEACHER CHILD RATIOS IN CLASS
SIZE AND ENSURING THAT THEIR
CHILD OBSERVATIONAL ASSESSMENT
WE ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS
EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR THREE
YEAR OLDS WITH DISABILITIES
SO THAT THEIR THOSE INCLUSIVE
CLASSROOMS AS WE MOVE INTO
THE FIFTEEN MILLION OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TEEKAY AND KEEP TEACHERS WE
ALSO GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT KNOWING
THAT PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR TEACHERS IS CRITICAL AND
THAT THE LEARNING THIRTY KM
K¿T JURORS IS IMPORTANT AS
THEY ADDRESS THOSE YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AS THEY CAN AND
UNDERSTANDING DEVELOPMENTAL
STAGES AND PROGRESSION OF
LEARNING IS CRITICAL AS WELL
AS PROVIDING FULL INCLUSION
AND SUPPORTING DOING LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC DEEPLY SUPPORTING
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICE AS AS
WE LOOK AT THE G.
CARE REQUIREMENTS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION IN
THIS PROJECT THAT THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN STATUTE HE K.
TEACHER REQUIREMENTS NEEDS
TO BE REEXAMINED IN LIGHT OF
THE RECENT MASTER PLAN AND
APPRECIATE THE EXTENSION OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF TIMELINE
REQUIREMENTS UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO ALLOW THESE
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS TO
HAPPEN OTHER KEY PIECES ABOUT
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION LOOKING AT IT'S
SOMETHING AROUND ENSURING THAT
THE WORKFORCE IS PREPARED TO
WORK WITH THE EVEN YOUNGER EACH
GREAT BRITAIN THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF THE MASTER PLANNER AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
PRESCHOOL THROUGH THIRD GRADE
ALIGNMENT WE THINK THAT THIRTY
MILLION TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS
TO ADDRESS THAT THAT COULD GO
FURTHER ST SUPPORTING ALIGNMENT
IN KIJIJI ACROSS THE S.
B.
P.
T.
K.
AND K.
AND REALLY EATEN
CERTAIN NOT BURKE B.
K.
YOUR YOUR SIESTA KEY ANTI K.
TEACHERS ACCESS THAT MANY I
MEAN WE APPRECIATE THAT TWO
HUNDRED NINETY PRETTY CAMPUS
STUDIES IN THIS BUDGET SINCE
THE SAUDIS ARE KEY COMPONENT
TO ADDRESS ANY EXTENSION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THAT'S RIGHT TO ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU ALL ARE START
OFFER NO SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
CERTAINLY HAVE QUESTIONS
HERE SO I WANNA I WANNA FOCUS
THIS ON -- I'M KIND OF LIKE
FOUR BUCKETS HERE FIRST IS
THE OVERALL -- ADDITION --
TO WOULD BE SOME TYPE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE IN THE
CURRENT KIND OF FRAMEWORK
-- A THIRD BE SOME OF THE
THIS THIS THE STANDARDS IN
AND -- POLICIES FOR EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND FOURTH IS THE
THE BIG PIECES MONEY --
IN THE FUNDING SO I GUESS
THAT THE FIRST THING IS THE
BIG PICTURE IS THAT WE'VE
ALL COME TO THE CONCLUSION
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
THAT EARLY EDUCATION
MATTERS AND THAT PRE K.
MATTERS AND READILY ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT IT'S NOT JUST FOUR YEAR
OLDS YOU'RE NOT JUST BORN AT
THE AGE OF FOUR HE CAN ENTER
KINDERGARTEN NEXT YEAR BUT
ZERO THROUGH FIVE COMPONENT
BUT WE'VE ALL -- CAME THE
CONCLUSION THAT THAT ONE YEAR
OF HIGH QUALITY PRE K.
REALLY MAKES A DIFFERENCE --
FOR FOR KINDERGARTEN READINESS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS -- BUT MORE
THAN ONE YEAR MULTIPLE YEARS
AND IN TWO YEARS WOULD MAKE
AN EVEN BIGGER DIFFERENCE AND
SO -- THAT'S THE ONE THE FIRST
EXAM WANNA GET AS WITH THE L.
A.
L.
ASKED IS WHAT YOU DO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND IS NOTED WE
SPEND ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR THREE CD HE TO
SUBSIDIZE -- FOUR YEAR OLDS
TO PARK LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR
OLD FAMILIES TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM SO IF ALL OF
A SUDDEN ALL THOSE FOUR YEAR
OLDS WERE IN THE L.
E.
A.
BASED TEEKAY THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT WHICH WE'LL GET TO A
LITTLE BIT THE FUNDING OF
THAT -- YOU HAVE A BILLION
DOLLARS IT CERTAINLY WE COULD
EXPAND ACCESS FOR ZERO THREE
THREE SO THE SAME -- PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS CONSERVE MORE THREE
YEAR OLDS AND WE CAN SERVE
MORE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT JUST
FROM THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PERSPECTIVE IF YOU BELIEVE
THAT EARLY EDUCATION MATTERS
IF YOU ARE A LOW INCOME AND KID
IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU GET TWO
YEARS OF FREE PUBLICLY FUNDED
HIGH QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION
THAT REALLY IS GOING TO BE A
DIFFERENCE MAKER AS WE ATTEMPT
TO ADDRESS OUR STUBBORN -- YOU
KNOW ACHIEVEMENT OPPORTUNITY
GAP AS KIDS INTO THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO I THINK THAT'S
THE ROUTE THAT WE OUGHT TO
GO CERTAINLY THIS IS A BUDGET
PROPOSAL HERE ON THE ONE TIME
SIDE THERE ARE COMPANION BILLS
IN THE SENATE THE ASSEMBLY
MORALIZING THIS THIS KIND OF
VISION SO -- THAT BEING SAID
THE OVERALL VISION AS FAR AS
WHAT WE DO -- NOW AS YOU NOTED
THERE ARE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
LIKE IN LOS ANGELES -- THAT
THAT DO THIS -- EXTENDED
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
AND HAVE KIDS ENTER BEFORE
THEY THEY TURN FIVE AND THEN
THEY'RE NOT FUNDED AND THEN
THEY THEY GET EIGHTY EIGHT
ONCE THE KID TURNS FIVE --
AND YOU MENTIONED EARLIER SOME
HAVE THESE MIX SYSTEMS LIKE
SAN DIEGO SO I GUESS THE GOOD
THAT THE QUESTION HERE ALL
ASPECTS OF THE MY ONE QUESTION
HERE ON THIS ONE IS DO WE WANT
TO ALLOW DISTRICTS -- NOW TO
BE MORE -- ENTREPRENEURIAL
IN AND ALLOW THEM TO START
COLLECTING -- EIGHTY EIGHT
RIGHT AWAY IN THIS NEXT YEAR
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
THAT FOR EXAMPLE F.
L.
A.
STAR THIS -- ON JULY ONE
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BE
OPEN TO ALLOWING THEM TO GET
EIGHTY EIGHT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE YEAR NOT JUST ONCE THIS
MONTH THE STUDENT TURNS FIVE
THIS IS SERRA BURDEN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO THAT PARTICULAR FEATURE
OF OF EXPANDING THE PROGRAM
AND THAT WAY IT'S ALL PART
OF OUR PROPOSAL -- I KNOW
THERE'S LARGER CONSIDERATIONS
IN TERMS OF EXPANDING ADA IN
THAT REGARD -- I WOULD HIT
IT OFF TO MY COLLEAGUE HERE
READY TO SEE IF YOU HAD ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS ON THAT ISSUE
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES ALRIGHT ERIN
RADIANCE BARBARA FINANCED THAT
I'LL LET MY COLLEAGUE SAID
IT YOU KNOW WE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OFFICIAL POSITION ON ON
SUCH A FRAMEWORK AS YOU LAID
OUT I THINK I WOULD POINT
OUT THOUGH -- BUT THE WAY
IT'S STRUCTURED RIGHT NOW YOU
THINK PROBABLY NEED ONE TIME
BONDS -- THAT REALLY ALLOWS
US TO MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE CAN WE CAN PUT
TOWARDS HEALTHIER FAT BY THE
DANCE CURRENTLY TOWARDS ALL OF
OUR OTHER PROPOSALS LIKE ARE
NOT SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY
INTERVENTION GRANTS IT CETERA
BY HAVING THIS BE ONE TIED
TO ACCEPT THAT WE ALLOW EIGHT
EIGHT INCREASE THEN YOU YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE TO REDUCE SOME
OTHER PROPOSAL AND SO THIS
IS WHAT WE THOUGHT MADE THE
MOST SENSE AND WAS THE MOST
PRUDENT IN OUR POWER APPROACH
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
BUT CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
THE CONVERSATION IT'S A VERY
THERE DOES A LOT OF COMPETING
PRIORITIES OUT THERE FOR ELLIE
EIGHT AND AND ADA CERTAINLY
IS ONE OF THE SO WE RECOGNIZE
THAT OKAY THANK YOU I'M ON THAT
JUST THAT JUST A COMMENT THAT
I I THINK THAT IF WE ARE GOING
TO PROVIDE ONE TIME MONEY FOR
DISTRICTS TO -- KENNETH SPRING
INTO THIS WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT ALLOWING THEM TO GET
CAUGHT PROPERLY COMPENSATED I
KNOW THAT SOME DISTRICTS HAVE
ALREADY ASKED YOU KNOW WOULD
WE BE OPEN TO THAT AND I DOES
NOT YOUR PROPOSAL BUT I THINK
THAT'S OUR PEOPLE THAT'S WHAT
WE THINK THAT WE WOULD PUT
FORWARD IN OUR AND OUR FINAL
BUDGET HERE TO ALLOW DISTRICTS
THAT WANT TO START NOW TIP TO
COLLECT AT EIGHTY EIGHT -- A
YEAR ROUND -- AS FAR AS THE
THAT THE STANDARDS I KNOW --
WE HAVE SEPARATE LEGISLATION
OUT THERE BUT BEFORE US IS
IS THE PROPOSAL TODAY AS FAR
AS -- THIS PROPOSAL ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN AND THIS
THESE QUALITY STANDARDS THE
RATIOS AND SO FORTH DOES --
CITY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THAT NOW BEFORE WE EXPAND OR
-- OR KICK OR DOWN THE ROAD
ALL THIS IS A MEMBER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M SO
PART OF WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING
AN INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM
IS PHASED OUT OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS WE DON'T THINK SHORT
TERM THIS WILL HAVE A LARGE
EFFECT ON TO THE STANDARDS THAT
NEED TO BE A LOT AND AS OF NOW
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
A BIG PART OF WHAT'S OUTLINED
IN THE MASTER PLAN -- AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE HAVE A
LONGER TERM PLAN TO ADDRESS THE
THE NEEDS OF AN EXPANDED TKA
PROGRAMMER PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS WELL
OKAY THE CD II WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
AS FAR AS STANDARDS AND RATIOS
DO WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT
NOW AS WE PUT MONEY AND FOR --
ONE TIME SUPPORT TO EXPAND TO
GET SICK WE HAVE SARAH NOBLE
MORGAN ADDRESS THAT SIR I THINK
YOU CHAIR THEY'RE NOT WILL
BARGAIN CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO START ADDRESSING
IT NOW SO THAT WE DON'T EXPAND
UTK SO FAR WITHOUT GETTING
THOSE STANDARDS IN PLACE WE
ALSO HEARD FROM SOME TEACHERS
THAT WHEN THEY HAVE TWENTY
FOUR TO TWENTY EIGHT KIDS IN A
CLASSROOM IN JUST ONE TEACHER
THAT THEY GET PRETTY STRETCHED
AND AS YOU LOOK AT HAVING
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER FORCED
TO REALLY ARE PRESCHOOL AGE
THAT THEY WOULD NEED THAT RENT
MULTIPLE TEACHERS IN THAT GREAT
SIZE REDUCED WE HAVE THE BEST
SUPPORT EVERY CHILD DEVELOPMENT
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
REALLY ADDRESSING THE LEARNING
STANDARDS AND ENSURING THAT
IT IS A PRESCHOOL BASED ON
THE RISK OF ANIMATIONS AS YOU
DO YOU THINK ET K.
PERSONS TO CARRY
YES THAT COULD OCCUR ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT -- I CAN'T
IMAGINE BEING A TEACHER IN
GENERAL FOR A FIRST GRADE OR
KINDERGARTEN WITH THIRTY KIDS
BUT -- I TEACH A CLASS ROOM
WITH THAT MANY IN ONE ADULT I
THINK JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
SO -- I'M NOT TRYING TO MIX
HERE OUR POLICY PROPOSALS AND
AND THE BUDGET BUT HAVING YOU
KNOW THE THE THE TWO ADULTS IN
THE CLASSROOM AND THE SMALLER
RATIOS I THINK YOU KNOW MAKES
SENSE FOR THESE EARLY GRADES
LASTLY I WANTED TO GO TO THIS
TO THIS POINT THAT -- THAT IS
MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA AND
ELADIO -- THAT HAVE HAD HAD
TALKED ABOUT AND SO WE HAVE
MISTER COUPON ON THE FROM L.
L.
C.
THEIR JUST SARAH CORTEZ NUMBER
SEVERAL DALY I CAN ANSWER
ANY SPECIFIC COMPANIES THE
REQUESTED YEAH YEAH SO I
MISTER COUPON OR OR OR YOU
MISTER CABRAL TALKED ABOUT THE
INTERPLAY WITH -- PROP NINETY
EIGHT AND THIS RAINY DAY FUND
AND THE EXPANSION OF T.
K.
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE AS MUCH OF A
DROP IN ATA SELL SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE L.
A.
N.
AND DECLINING ENROLLMENT
DISTRICTS SEE THIS AS A
LIFELINE LIKE I'M LOSING
STUDENTS BRING IN MORE TEA CASE
STUDENTS I COULD STABILIZE OUR
SITUATION THE DISTRICT AS WELL
AS FOCUSING ON THE BENEFITS
OF EARLY EDUCATION -- YOU
KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATE
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WHICH
WERE SUPPOSED TO DO AS WELL
OF COURSE OVER HERE THE THE
YOU CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT WELL
THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY MORE
MONEY PAYING FOR THAT THE NEW
KID YOU'RE JUST RE SHUFFLING
FROM THE ENTIRE SIX MILLION
POPULATION ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND GRANTED WE HAVE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND -- INCREASE
PROP NINETY EIGHT WE'RE STILL
UNDER FUNDING EDUCATION IN
GENERAL AND IN MY OPINION
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES --
SO YOU COULD MAKE THE ARGUMENT
WELL FEWER KIDS MORE MONEY
WE'RE GIVING YOU ANYWAY YOU
THESE THINGS THAT MATCH UP
YOU SHOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM
SERVING THESE ADDITIONAL
KIDS SINCE YOU'RE DECLINING
EVERY YEAR AND GETTING MORE
MONEY BUT THIS OTHER PIECE IS
REALLY INTERESTING TO ME AND
I WONDER IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN
IT TO US THAT THIS NINETY
RAINY DAY FUND INTERPLAY WITH
SEXUALLY LESS MONEY HAVING TO
BE STASHED AWAY AND COULD GO
TO PROP NINETY EIGHT TO PAY
FOR STE -- A MAJOR PIECE OR
MORE THAN HALF OF HALF OF EACH
ADDITIONAL KID IN GOLDEN TICKET
YES UNLIMITED MAY JUST QUICKLY
GOING BACKWARD CONTACTED YOU
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF THE
OVERALL TO GUARANTEE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE ARE IN A MIDDLE
SCHOOL PROTESTS ONE FORMULA
AND OUR EXPECTATIONS THAT WILL
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS THAT'S HOW
THE COMPANY DURING PEOPLE ARE
OUR PERMITTED TO WORK IT'LL
BE A PICTURE OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUES THAT WILL GO TO PARK
TO PROPAGATE SO IT'S NOT GONNA
BE GOING UP OR DOWN BASED ON
CHANGES IN THE TENANTS LIKE
AS SO AS YOU MENTIONED BY THE
GOVERNMENT THAT IS DECLINING
ENROLLMENT IS HAPPENING TO ME
FIRST OF TWENTY IS GOING UP
BUT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ONE OF
THE CONCERNS FROM SOME FOLKS
ABOUT DOING SOMETHING LIKE
EXPANDING TRANSACTION CONFIRMED
THAT THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS
NOT GOING TO GO UP IF YOU HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL TWO TICKETS
I'M SORRY AND I THINK THAT'S
STILL THE CASE BIG PICTURE IN
THE LONG RUN -- DOESN'T GO UP
THE WE STILL THINK THAT YOU
COULD FUND THE PROGRAM YOU WANT
TO WITHIN GROWTH MATURITY AND
OKAY WHEN THEY ISSUE THAT YOU
MENTIONED IS VERY SPECIFIC TO
THIS -- THIS BUDGET YEAR SO IN
BUDGET YEAR BECAUSE REVENUES
HAVE GROWN SUBSTANTIALLY THERE
IS A REQUIREMENT THAT SOME OF
THE FUNDING -- THAT'S GOING
TOWARDS THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR BE DEPOSITED
INTO THE PROPOSITION NINETY
-- NUMBER THAT THE WAY THAT
TAX -- THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FORMULAS THAT ARE THAT GO
TO COULD PROTECT IN TERMS OF
DETERMINING WHAT THE AMOUNT
WOULD BE DEPOSITED INTO THAT
RESERVE BUTTON THERE IS WITH
A CALCULATION TO ENSURE THAT
YOU'RE TAKING YOUR BASELINE
PROGRAM I'M HERE WITH A
FUNDING TO GROW BY A CERTAIN
THE WHOLE SOUL DISTRIBUTION
OF INTENTIONAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH THE END
OF YOUR DON'T INCREASE THE
AMOUNT THAT WOULD NEED TO
BE DISTRIBUTED OUT TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THIS YEAR I'M NOT
INTO THE RESERVE SO IF YOU
WERE STATE TO EXPAND -- ABOUT
SOME OF THE TRADITIONAL CARE
OUR PROGRAM THIS YEAR ON IT
WOULDN'T EVEN YOU HAVE TO
SAY CUT OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE IN THE GOVERNMENT WE JUST
NEED THAT THE AMOUNT WOULD
BE DEPOSITED IN THE RESERVE
WOULD BE DECREASED YEAH SO
THAT THE THAT AMOUNT THIS
DEPOSITED IN THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT NOT FOR LACK OF A BETTER
DESCRIPTION HERE THAT GROWS
FOR THE STUDENTS SO IT'S ONE
TIME MONEY OR TAKING FROM
THERE FROM THE RAINY DAY PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUND PUTTING IN
THE PAST NINETY EIGHT BASS AND
THAT GROWS AS A STUDENTS GO
TO FIRST GRADE SECOND GRADE SO
FAR CORRECT THAT'S RIGHT IT'S
A LOST CAUSE THE PROBLEM THE
DEPOSIT IS A ONE TIME DEPOSIT
WHEN YOU'RE GENERAL IDEA WITH
THE COMPANY TO RESERVE DEPOSIT
IS THE NEXT YEAR THAN WE WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE HAD DEPOSITED
NOT MANY WOULD RESULT OR OTHER
ACTIVITIES IF YOU ARE SERVING
ADDITIONAL TICKET THIS YEAR
THAT MEANS YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR DOCTORS
YOU'RE FREE TO SELECTIVITY
COULD BE GOING TOWARD SERVING
THE CHILDREN ARE VIEWED AS
A WITH A LOT ABOUT A DOZEN
TICKETS COMING IN IF YOU'RE
SOFT ON IT IT IS A NEW YORKER
MEETINGS YOUR ONGOING PROBLEM
ANY RESOURCES FOR TRANSITION
KERN I'M THERE IS NOT AN
IMMEDIATE EFFECT IN THE CURRENT
YEAR IN TERMS OF MAKING CUTS
TO OTHER PROGRAMS WE WERE
WE WE NOTED WE THINK GIVEN
GOVERNMENT GUARANTEED YOU COULD
FIND OUT EXPLAINS IN TERMS
NGUYEN YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO DO MUCH OTHER PROGRAMMATIC
AUGMENTATIONS BUT AGAIN IF IT'S
A PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE
WE FIGURED WE DETECTED THE
DOCTOR WELL UNDER THE CURRENT
ON ROAD FOR CUSTOMER CITY AND
THEN YOU SEE SAID WERE IN THIS
TEST ONE FOR THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE WHICH IS A FINITE POT
OF MONEY FOR EDUCATION BUT ONCE
WE LEAVE TEST ONE THEN THESE
NEW STUDENTS ARE GENERATING
EIGHTY EIGHT PER STUDENT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT ALTHOUGH
I THINK UNDER THE LATEST --
IN ORDER OUTLOOK COMMITTEE
MET MOST OF THE LATEST ON
OUR FORECAST THAT WE'VE DONE
BUT WE DIDN'T TEST ONE IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE CRIME IN
IN ALMOST THREE HOURS SO I
COULD OR ITS POSITION BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD BE IF
THIS ONE ARE MOVING FORWARD
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO REPORT EVEN
THE THREE FOUR FIVE YEARS IN
OUR AND THEN THAT CAN YOU CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THAT THAT THE --
THAT THE FINANCIAL SCENARIO WHY
LOOK DISTRICTS WHO HAVE MAJOR
DECLINING ENROLLMENT ARE SO
INTERESTED IN TEEKAY EXPANSION
BESIDES THE FACT THAT I THINK
HOPEFULLY AND ALTRUISTIC THINGS
THEY BELIEVE THAT MORE EARLY
EDUCATION FOR MORE CALIFORNIA'S
A BETTER THING FOR OUR OUR
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR
ECONOMY AND SO FORTH BUT FROM
A FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE YOU
KNOW MOST DISTRICTS AREN'T
DECLINING ENROLLMENTS ITSELF
THE DISTRICTS THAT THAT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS WHY DID
THE VIEW IT SO FAVORABLY
FINANCIALLY WHAT FROM WHAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING AT THE
MOMENT WHEN THE DISTRICT
IS IN THE COMING IN WITHOUT
THE OFTENTIMES WOULD MAKE
HIM -- HELLO MORE FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES IN THE PART WAS
GOING ON AS YOU MIGHT BE HAVING
YOU KNOW THESE DECLINES ARE
HAPPENING OFTENTIMES PRETTY
MINOR BUT FOR EXAMPLE YOU'RE
SEEING ONE OF YOUR KIDS PER PER
CLASSROOM -- AND STRANDED SO
YOU'RE ALREADY SMALL DECLINES
BUT YOU HAVE SOME FIXED COSTS
BUT YOU CAN CERTAINLY CUT SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE JUST
HAVING ONE FEWER KICKOFF IN
YOUR OLD SCHOOL -- YOU'RE
GONNA GET MUSCLE SPECIFIC
FUNDING BECAUSE OF THAT BUT
YOUR NUMBERS ARE GONNA BE ABLE
TO REDUCE YOUR MORE HORSES SO
THOSE THINGS OVER TIME COMPOUND
TO BECOME MORE CHALLENGING
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
IF YOU WERE TO EXPAND IT --
THAT COULD OFFSET SOME OF THE
CLINTON IN A MOMENT I NEED TO
WRITE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE AND
TO THE -- TO GET SOME OF THOSE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES -- -- ARE
ARE GREATER THAN THE INCREASED
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEW
COULD NOT BE THAT DISTRICTS
WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL ARE IN
BETTER FISCAL POSITION THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE PERFECT AND IN
LAST FINANCIAL QUESTION ABOUT
THIS I KIND OF MENTIONED THIS
EARLIER BUT WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO THE NOTION THAT THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS DECLINING
ENROLLMENT WHAT'S THAT DROPPED
AGAIN THE PERCENTAGE WERE
DROPPING BY EVERY YEAR DECLINE
WE WE HAVE BEEN DROPPING BY
IT'S LESS THAN ONE PERCENT BOTH
GOING TO COME TO THE RIGHT THE
MOST RECENT DATA WE'VE BEEN
DROPPING I THINK OUR FOCUS
WAS MORE THAN ABOUT ONE AND
A HALF PERCENT FOR THE COMING
YEAR YEAH AND OF COURSE IS
THIS PAST YEAR WAS YOU KNOW
ALL THAT'S ROTH AND ALL KINDS
OF FUNKY NUMBERS BECAUSE THAT
THAT PANDEMIC WITH SPECIALLY
THE EARLIER YOUNGER GRADES SO
THIS NOTION THAT WE ARE HAVING
DECLINING IN ENROLLMENT SO
WE'RE SERVING THE OUR STUDENTS
AND THEN PROP NINETY EIGHT AS
AT THIS ALL TIME HIGH GRANTED
SOMEONE SAY SCHOOLS ARE WERE
NOT PROPERLY FUND IN THE FIRST
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA BUT WHAT
DO YOU RESPOND TO THE NOTION
THAT WELL IF YOU HAVE IF YOU
IF IF CALIFORNIANS HAVING FEWER
KIDS IN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM WE'RE GIVING THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM MORE MONEY
ANYWAY -- MAYBE DOESN'T IT
ISN'T THAT ISN'T THAT MUCH
OF A STRETCH TO TO THROW AN
ADDITIONAL RTK KIDS IN THE MIX
PEOPLE WE RECORDS WAS THAT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IS IS
JUST HOW DO YOU WANT TO SPEND
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN A
WAY THAT YOU THINK MIGHT BE
BEST FOR CERTAIN DIFFERENCES
SO OBVIOUSLY IN THERE ARE
THERE ARE SOME OPTIONS ARE
YOU CAN DECIDE FOR EXAMPLE
YOU WANT TO USE SOME OF THOSE
INCREASES FUNDING TO AUGMENT
OR SUPPLEMENT YOUR EXISTING
CONTROL PROGRAMS OF CIRCUITS
WERE CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN
SCHOOL THAT'S DEFINITELY ONE OF
COURSE YOU COULD TAKE ANOTHER
APPROACH IF YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING LIKE TO K.
AND IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE TAKEN
OFF OF THE STATE PRESCHOOL
THIS IS A REAL ONE OF THEIR
KEY FUNDING FOR THE EARLIER
GRADES WE WANT TO HELP SUPPORT
AND EXPAND PRESCHOOL SERVICES
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE -- YOUR
BENEFITS FIRST INFINITY LATER
DOWN THE LINE I THINK THEY'RE
GONNA BE DOING BETTER WE THINK
ANY OF THOSE OF COURSE ISN'T SO
I THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE --
YOU KNOW IT BURLESQUE CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHAT YOU
NEED YOU GENERATED AND MORE
AT THE CAN BROADLY ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF PROPERTY WHEN YOU'RE
AVAILABLE WHAT MIGHT BE THE
BEST USES WILL SPEND THOSE
FUNDS TO THE BANK BECAUSE
OKAY AND THEN LASTLY I I DIDN'T
GET TO IT BUT AS THE AGENDA
ALLUDES TO ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT THAT THE GOVERNOR IN
THE MASTER PLAN AND CAN BRACE
TEEKAY NOT THIS IS THE MOST
LOGICAL WE ALREADY HAVE A TAKE
A SYSTEM IN PLACE IT'S WE HAVE
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS AND YOU
COULD HAVE A PART PROFESSIONAL
AND THEY'RE STILL PICK THE
CORRECT RATIO OF IS THE FACT
THAT -- IN A RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT A UNIVERSAL PROGRAM IS A
BETTER PROGRAM ON YOU SIR YOU
SERVE BROADER SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION -- PLUS YOU DON'T
HAVE THIS INEQUITY WORK ON KIDS
BORN DURING THE FALL WHEN THE
LOTTERY GET A FREE YEAR OF OF
PUBLICLY FUNDED PRE K.
ABOUT HOW FOR -- A ART
OTHERS THAT THAT T.
K.
REALLY IS A DIFFERENCE
MAKER AND HELPS ALL GROUPS
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE WHO
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN WE
HAVE ESSENTIALLY A TEN YEAR
PILOT PROJECT WITH A QUARTER
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
THAT'S SHOWN TO BE OKAY SO
I I KNOW WE HAVE A SOMEONE
EVERYBODY THAT ESTIMATES
ON THE NUMBER OF DONALD
WELL I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO BE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION AND EXPANDING --
POSSIBLY SEVENTY K.
-- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
SEE IN MY DISTRICT DISASTER
PLANNING AND ROMAN WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S GOING PROP NINETY
EIGHT DOLLARS IN BONDS A BILL
AVAILABLE BUT THIS IS ALSO
A REALLY AN IMPORTANT MOMENT
FOR US TO HELP THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND THE MIDDLE CLASS
WHO CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY PRESCHOOL
BECAUSE THEY DON'T MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY FOR IT BUT THEN
THEY MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY AND
DON'T NECESSARILY QUALIFY FOR
STATE PRESCHOOL HEAD START
-- STAGE -- CAL WORKS AT ON
TOP OF IT IT'S PROBABLY THE
MOST CRITICAL AND CRUCIAL TIME
THAT WE FUND AND EXPAND TKA
-- BECAUSE OUR KIDS THAT AND
I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO WILL
BE FOUR IN APRIL SO THIS IS A
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO ME
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY
AND GIVEN MY BACKGROUND AS A
PRESCHOOL PROVIDER BUT FOR THE
LAST YEAR THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS HAVE BEEN AT HOME AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BIRTHDAY
PARTIES THEY'RE NOT HANGING
OUT IN IN YOU KNOW IN PLACES
WHERE THEY'RE PLAYING WITH
OTHER KIDS WERE EVEN THOUGH
IT MAY NOT BE IN THE CLASSROOM
OR PLAYBASE SETTING LIKE
QUALITY CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL
ON THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
COMPONENTS OF FOUNDATIONS THAT
ARE CREATED IN THOSE NORMAL
ENVIRONMENTS ARE NOT HAVEN'T
BEEN HAPPENING FOR A YEAR SO
THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL TIME
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION --
UNLIKE MY FIRST QUESTIONS ARE
-- UP QUITE A FEW QUESTIONS --
UNLIKE THE CURRENT T.
K.
PROGRAM WHICH IS BASED ON
ELIGIBILITY THE GOVERNOR'S
HE CAN ROMAN PROPOSAL WOULD
PRIORITIZE GRANT FUNDING
BASED IN PART ON ELEAZAR --
PROPORTION OF ADULT LANGUAGE A
BILL LANGUAGE STUDENTS I'M WHY
NOT TAKE A PHASED IN APPROACH
AVAIL OF ELIGIBILITY SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE SAW WHEN WE AND
IT MOVED KINDERGARTEN FROM
DECEMBER SECOND CUT OFF TO --
SEPTEMBER SECOND CUT OFF WHY
COULDN'T WE JUST KIND OF DO A
REVERSE PHASE AND -- LEAD THAT
-- WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WOULD YOU
BE OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THAT AND IT AND THE FOLLOW
UP QUESTION THERE AS WELL IS
IS IT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
GOAL TO PRIORITIZE T.
CARROLL MET FOR ASK RIP RISK
POPULATIONS WHILE KATIE TWELVE
MAINTAINS UNIVERSAL ACCESS
HELLO AGAIN THIS IS -- SERRA
BURNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO ON TO GET YOUR
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT PHASING
IN THIS PROGRAM SO SO THESE
PARTICULAR PROPOSALS ARE REALLY
FOCUSED ON BUILDING CAPACITY IN
THE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT OF MORE
TRANSIT MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FAMILIES ACCESS TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND EARLY
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
ON THAT'S WHY WHAT YOU SEE
IN THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
UP UP GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE I MEAN FOR
THESE INCENTIVE GRANTS I'M
NOT TO MENTION THE PART OF
THE INCENTIVE GRANTS TO --
ARE PHASED IN OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS -- AND THE REASON FOR
DOING THIS IS SO THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO COLLECT DATA ON THE
FIRST YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO TO SEE HOW MANY MORE A
FOUR YEAR OLD ELLIE IS WILL
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR -- THEN PROVIDE THE GRANT
FUNDING IN THE LATTER TWO YEARS
SO WE BELIEVE THAT COUPLED
WITH THE CAPACITY BUILDING
MEASURES FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL PROVIDE A VERY STRONG
BASED ON FOR EXPANDING THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM -- AND THEN TO YOUR
SECOND QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT THIS PRIORITIZE IS AT
RISK -- STUDENTS ARE THERE IS
LANGUAGE WITHIN THE PROPOSALS
THAT DESCRIBES SOME OF THE
PRIORITIES THAT WE LIKE TO SEE
FROM GRANT APPLICATIONS WHICH
INCLUDE VARIOUS PRIORITIES LIKE
ELLIE IS THAT SERVE A HIGHER
PROPORTION OF THE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS INCLUSIVE CLASSROOMS
-- AND AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
HOPEFULLY THAT GETS AYE BOTH
OF YOUR QUESTIONS BUT THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF INSIGHT INTO THE
PROPOSAL'S THEMSELVES GOT IT M.
IS THE T.
CAN ROMAN PROPOSAL LIMITED TO
ONE TIME FUNDING BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS START UP
COSTS ARE THE PRIMARY BARRIER
IN EXPANDING THE PROGRAMS OR DO
OTHER PRIORITIES LIMIT ON GOING
FUNDING AND WHAT PRIORITIES
WOULD YOU SAY ARE LIMITING
YEAH SO I I WOULD SAY THAT
THAT'S DEFINITELY PART OF THAT
THAT HAVING THESE CAPACITY
BUILDING MEASURES IS REALLY
IMPORTANT GETTING THESE --
ONE TIME DOLLARS INTO START
BUILDING THE STRUCTURE IS
WHAT'S DRIVING MOST OF WHAT
YOU SEE IN THESE PROPOSALS
-- AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE ALWAYS
BALANCING IN OUR FISCAL PICTURE
AS WELL SO THAT'S CERTAINLY A
PART OF IT BUT WE DEFINITELY
SEE A NEED FOR ADDING THESE
SUPPORTS DOING IT WITH THESE
DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IN ORDER TO BUILD OFF
OF THAT AT A LATER TIME
IS A PROPOSED
FUNDING RIGHT FOR THE T.
CAN ROLL MEANT GRANT EQUAL TO
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE L.
C.
FF RATE INTENDED TO ALIGN
WITH THE AMOUNT PROVIDED
FOR PART TIME STUDENTS
AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
SO IT IS INTENDED TO BE
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT ELEAZER
RECEIVING IN TERMS OF EIGHTY
EFFORT TICE'S STUDENTS
CURRENTLY -- AND IF YOU HAVE
FURTHER QUESTIONS -- I'D HAVE
TO PASS IT OFF TO MY COLLEAGUE
BUT THAT'S SORT OF THE BASELINE
ANSWER FOR YOU RIGHT THERE
IF YOU'RE CALLING
ON ON THE LINE
YES HI -- OVER THIS VIDEO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN
AND I I DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENT OTHER THAN
-- MY COLLEAGUES -- BERGNER
MENTIONED THAT I AM AWARE WAS
NOT DEVELOPED WITH SPECIFIC
REGARD TO -- THE RATE THAT
YOU MENTIONED THANK YOU I'M
SO TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WORK FORCE -- ONE OF THE
VERY -- GLARING ISSUES ON THE
BACKGROUND I WAS READING WAS
THE RATIOS -- CURRENTLY IN
TKD ONE AND TWO AND AND AND
-- ASSEMBLY MEN ADJOURNMENT
MCCARTY BROUGHT THIS UP --
ERASED CURRENT TICKET RATIOS
ARE ONE TO THIRTY THREE --
AND COMING I JUST CANNOT EVEN
IMAGINE COMING FROM A PRESCHOOL
PROVIDER BACKGROUND -- NOT
HAVING -- SMALLER RATIOS I
MEAN WE ALL AIM FOR SMALLER
RATIOS BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES
DELIVER QUALITY I'M PRESCHOOL
SO I'M WHAT WHAT IS WHAT
WOULD YOUR PROPOSED RATIOS BE
THIS IS SERRA BURNER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE'RE
NOT PROPOSING ANY CHANGES --
TO SO THE RATIOS AT THIS TIME
I WILL SAY THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS I WILL GO
TOWARDS EXPANDING THE POOL
OF TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
TEACHERS AS WELL AS INCREASING
THEIR COMPETENCIES AND
SOME OF THOSE INCLUDE ARE
PROVIDING INSTRUCTION INCLUSIVE
CLASSROOMS AND SUPPORT FOR
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING LEARNING
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES
-- RESTORATIVE PRACTICES IN
MITIGATING IMPLICIT BIASES SO
IT DOESN'T QUITE GET AT THAT
RATIO QUESTIONS BUT THE INTENT
OF THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM IS IS TO GET AT THE
BUILDING THESE COMPETENCIES
AND INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
TEACHERS OVERALL AND I'M NOT
SURE IF IF YOU KNOW ANYONE
CAN ANSWER THIS QUESTION BUT
WHAT AT IT'S OBVIOUSLY VITAL
THAT -- DO WE PUT FUNDING
TOWARDS GROWING THE WORKFORCE
DOING NO -- WHAT HOW MANY EASY
PROFESSIONALS WOULD NEED TO
BE RECRUITED -- TO ACCOMMODATE
THE EXPANSION OF THIS PROGRAM
DOES THE L.
A.
L.
IF IF NOT THAT'S OKAY YOU
GUYS CAN GET BACK TO ME THERE
WERE TIED WITH THE LA -- A
WE DON'T HAVE ANY ESTIMATE AT
THIS POINT BUT WILL DO SOME
THINKING AND WE CAN WORK WITH
STAFF TO GET BACK TO YOU I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT I'M SO
WHAT ARE THE COMPARATOR ALL
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
QUALIFY A TEACHER FOR T.
K.
CLASSROOMS -- CAN CURRENCY K.
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS CONTINUE
WORKING AND TAKE A CLASSROOMS
WITHOUT A CHILD DEVELOPMENT
PERMIT -- TWENTY FOUR UNITS
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
OR CHILD DEVELOPMENT EDUCATION
AND DO THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
GOING TO AFFECTS ON A FACT
ON AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ONLY APPLY TO NEW T.
K.
TEACHERS
ANYONE
DID YOU HEAR THE QUESTION
YOU WANT TO HAVE THIS REPEAT
IT YEAH I CAN ATTEST WHAT
ARE THE COMPARATO EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS THAT QUALIFY
A TEACHER FOR TEEKAY
K.
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS CONTINUE
WORKING AND TAKE A CLASSROOMS
WITHOUT A CHILD DEVELOPMENT
PERMIT OR TWENTY FOUR UNITS
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD AND HER
CHILD DEVELOPMENT EDUCATION
WE'LL START WITH THAT ONE
NUMBER OF BLOOD THINNER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL
TAKE IT AS STOP IT YOU FOR
THAT AND -- THAT PREPARATION
PROGRAMS FOR MULTIPLE SUBJECT
-- CREDENTIALED CANDIDATES
INCLUDE TECHNOLOGIES BUT
SPECIFIC TO INSTRUCTION
RELATED TO -- TEACHING CHILDREN
AGES FIVE AND OLDER -- WITH
REGARDS TO THAT TICE T.
K.
TEACHER CRITICAL REQUIREMENTS
-- THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL --
-- EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PREPARATION REQUIREMENTS IT'S
REALLY INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
TEEKAY TEACHERS -- PASSIVATION
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW CHILDREN
AGES THREE TO FIVE -- ARE ARE
DEVELOPING AN IN ORDER TO BEST
AND BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT
DEVELOPMENT -- MY COLLEAGUES
ARE MENTIONED -- SOME OF THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TEEKAY
PROPOSALS THAT YOU YOU SEE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ARE REALLY EIGHT INTENDED --
TO TARGET AND BETTER PREPARE
AND THOSE TEACHERS AS WELL AS
EXPAND THE POOL OF TEACHERS
THAT HAVE THAT -- HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE -- THREE TO FIVE YEAR OLDS
AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
AND ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON
THAT TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROCESS I THINK WE HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU AFTER
CONSULTING WITH THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING
AND I KNOW THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE -- A MEMBER ON THIS
PANEL YEAH I KNOW YOU GREAT
JAVA ANSWERING THAT QUESTION
THEN AGAIN IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WILL WILL PROBABLY
DISCUSS AGAIN IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH EVERYONE
THANK YOU GOOD QUESTIONS
CAN I JUST ASK ONE QUICK
FOLLOW UP QUESTION JUST
BECAUSE I WANNA GET LOST
ON IT FOR -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN YOU COME BACK ON
THE ON THE ON GOING FUNDING
QUESTION VERSUS ONE TIME
AS ONE ONE CLARIFICATION
YEAH I'M HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAPPY TO TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION DID YOU DID
YOU WANT TO TO -- ASK A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION JUST LIKE
CLARIFICATION A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION TO SOMEONE MEMBER
BY ADARSH QUESTION ABOUT --
THE ONE TIME MONEY IN SUPPORT
FOR FOR -- FOR IMPLEMENTATION
FOR START UP GRANT SO IF THE
GOVERNOR HAS EMBRACED TKA HAS
A WAY TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN YOUR PROVIDING IN THE MASTER
PLAN AND YOUR PROVIDING ONE
TIME MONEY INTO THESE THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES FOR START
UP FUNDS DOES THE GOVERNOR
VIEW THE CURRENT PROP NINETY
EIGHT STRUCTURE AS ADEQUATE
TO SUPPORT TEEKAY EXPANSION
FOR EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA SO
IF YOU CAN CLARIFY DEPARTMENT
FINANCES PERSPECTIVE ON THAT
RIGHT I THINK AT THE MOMENT
-- AS I SAID EARLIER I WOULD
JUST REITERATE MY EARLIER
COMMENT AND AND ALSO HOW TO
BUILD UPON WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
EDGAR CABRAL WITH L.
A.
O.
SHARED AS WELL THAT -- WE FEEL
AS FAR AS PRUDENT C.
IS CONCERNED WITH THE CURRENT
OUTLOOK -- I REMIND FOLKS THAT
THERE'S ALREADY EVEN WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S WHAT'S PROPOSED
EVEN WITH ALL THE THE FUNDING
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING AND
GROPING GUARANTEE -- WITH THE
REBOUND OR REVENUE -- AFTER
COAL BIT SO DIFFERENT BEING SO
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE THOUGHT
WAS GOING AFTER THE BUDGET
ACT WE ARE STILL PROPOSING
A THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR -- ESTIMATED K.
TWELVE A PORTION OF THE FOR --
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
AND I DON'T THINK THAT CAN BE
UNDERSTATED SO AT THE MOMENT
THAT'S WHY I KEEP REALLY IN
A COUNTY NOTHING DRUM THAT
-- THE BUDGET AS WE PROPOSE
THAT WE REALLY FEEL IS THE
MOST APPROPRIATE MAKES UP ONE
TIME AND ONGOING FUNDS AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE WORK TO A
WEEK WE WOULD HAVE CONCERNS
-- AND AND SAY THAT CAUTION
IS WARRANTED AROUND ALL OF A
SUDDEN HAVING IT YES THE INFLUX
OF ADA AND WHILE SOME ELLIE AS
MATE MIGHT FIND THAT HELPFUL
-- IT COULD PUT US VERY QUICKLY
AND A AND A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
ONGOING FUNDING AVAILABILITY
-- CONVERSATION THAN WE THINK
IS IS -- WARRANTED AT THIS TIME
OKAY WELCOME BACK MISTER
O'DONNELL GREAT THANK YOU
AND I WON APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO'S
ADVOCACY TO INCREASE T.
K.
AND SURVIVE IN A PRESCHOOL
CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE THEY
NEED AN ADVOCATE BUT I ALSO
THINK THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE
WHAT TO CAN HALF THE GRADE
TWELVE -- NEED AN ADVOCATE
TO AND MY CONCERN WAS SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE PROPOSALS IS
THERE REALLY THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE PRACTICAL AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND WHAT DO I
MEAN BY THAT CERTAINLY I WANT
TO SERVE AND DEVELOP A SYSTEM
FOR FOR FREE SCHOOL STUDENTS
AND TO FIND IT AND FIND IT
IS KEY BUT MY FEARS WERE JUST
TAKING FROM OTHER STUDENTS
AND GIVING IT TO SOME STUDENTS
AND THAT THAT'S WHERE MY
CONCERN COMES IN AND I'M SURE
THAT BEFORE IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND I THINK THE L.
A.
-- ACTUALLY ALLUDED TO IT WHAT
THE IMPACT OF SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS MIGHT BE -- IT COULD
BE IT COULD BE SIGNIFICANT WE
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
ADDING A GRADE LEVEL TO AN
ALREADY UNDER FUNDED T.
CAN HAVE TWELVE SYSTEM THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WITHOUT ADDING MORE MONEY TO
THAT SYSTEM WE'RE ACTUALLY JUST
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOWERING THE
TIGHT WE'RE LOWERING THE THE
AMOUNT WE FUND ALL GRADES HAD
IN AN IN AN ALREADY RADICALLY
UNDER FUNDED EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
WHERE ONE OF THE LOWEST IN THE
NATION ON A PER STUDENT BASIS
AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT WITHIN
THESE PROPOSALS I JUST UNDER
FUNDING EVERYBODY AND ADDING
STUDENTS I DON'T THINK REALLY
HELPS I THINK YEAH ADEQUATELY
FUNDING ALL STUDENTS IS REALLY
THE RESPONSIBLE THING TO DO IF
WE HAD IF WE HAD A T.
CARE DOES THIS MEAN WE'RE
TAKING AWAY FROM SIX CREATORS
IT -- EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
AND THAT'S MORE QUESTIONS
THIS TIME THAN THEY REALLY AN
OPINION BUT THAT THERE ARE IN A
LIFE OF THE POLICY DILEMMA AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AS A BODY
TO ADDRESS -- AND I'M LOOKING
AT THIS WHAT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR TO CANCEL THEY CAN
-- FACILITIES THAT SEEMS TO BE
RESPONSIBLE ONE TIME RIGHT ONE
TIME CAPITAL EXPENDITURE FIFTY
MILLION FOR EARLY EDUCATION
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
ONE TIME MONEY TO ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FOR GRANTS TO
INCREASE EARLY ACCESS I ASSUME
THAT MEANS LOTS OF FOR TEA CASE
STUDENTS I HAVE TO QUESTION
THE PRACTICAL AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT ARENA SAY
FOR ONE YEAR YOU HIRE TEACHERS
FOR ONE YEAR YOU DEVELOP
FACILITIES FOR THE STUDENTS
WE SHOULD HAVE A GREATER
COMMITMENT TO THAT EFFORT THAN
JUST ONE YEAR AND I GET WHY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING ONE
YEAR IS BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT
TO COMMIT THAT MONEY IN THE
OUT YEARS BECAUSE IF WE HAD A
ROUGHER TIMES IN THE ULTIMATE
IMPACT COULD BE THAT THEY WERE
TAKING MONEY AWAY FROM OTHER
GROUPS WERE JUST ADDING GRAYSON
FLATTENING THE AMOUNT SO THOSE
ARE KIND OF MY CONCERNS I MEAN
IT WAS EVEN ALLUDED TO THERE
SO -- WHAT SOMEONE FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE AND AS
SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORT THAT TO
FROM WHAT WAS YOUR WITH THEM
KIND OF YOU KNOW THANK YOU
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THAT WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THAT IS AYE ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE FOLKS FROM
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE
MERELY TALK ABOUT CLASS SIZE
REDUCTION FOR TEEKAY WE'VE GOT
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHERS THAT ARE
TEACHING LANGUAGE ARTS WITH
THIRTY EIGHT STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOM THIRTY EIGHT STUDENTS
IN THE CLASS AND THAT'S THIRTY
EIGHT ESSAYS OF THEIR TEACHING
FIVE PERIODS A DAY DO THE
MATH FIVE TIMES THIRTY EIGHT
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT THOSE THINGS
YEAH AND YOU GOTTA KEEP YOUR
STUDENTS ENGAGE IN THE DID YOU
GET YOU GET YOU KNOW TO KNOW
YOUR STUDENTS AND WE NEED CLASS
SIZE REDUCTION IN THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL -- SO AGAIN I I
THINK -- YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
THAT THEY SEE THIS IS THEIR
PATH TO REMAINING FISCALLY
SOLVENT I'M OPEN TO THAT I'M
SURE I WILL HEAR IT NOW AND I'M
I'M QUITE OPEN TO HEARING THAT
THAT THIS IS HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO REMAIN FISCALLY SOLVENT
BUT I THINK THE RESPONSIBLE
THING FOR US TO DO AS A BODY
IS TO COME TOGETHER AND SEE
HOW IDENTIFY HOW WE'RE GOING
TO PAY FOR THIS SO THAT WE DO
AT STUDENTS WE SCORE UP THE
FUNDING RIGHT WE JUST DON'T ADD
STUDENTS TO TO TO AN EXISTING
POOL OF DOLLARS AND THE L.
A.
O.
HAS PULLED POINTED OUT THAT
THE DOLLARS ARE STATIC MAYBE
IN A TEST TO YEAR THEY'RE NOT
AS THE CHAIRS POINT OUT WHERE
TO TEST ONE YEAR OF THIS YEAR
BUT I REALLY THINK AS A BODY
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER AND
IDENTIFY AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO FUND FREE SCHOOL
EDUCATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I DON'T THINK
-- IT'S FAIR TO SAY IT'S THE
EXISTING BUCKET OF DOLLARS THAT
WE NOW USED TO FUND K.
TWELVE EDUCATION SO THAT THAT
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S MY
POINT OF VIEW -- I KNOW WILL
HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS POLICY TOPIC I'VE BEEN
KIND OF FERVENT ON THIS POINT
NOT EVERYBODY APPRECIATES IT
BUT I THINK SOME DO THAT I
WANT I ASSURE THEIR GOAL IT'S
JUST HOW WE GET THERE IS WHERE
WE DIFFER AND THE IMPACTS OF
SOME OF THE POLICIES THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED WHAT WHAT THOSE
IMPACTS WILL BE ON THE EXISTING
-- DOLLAR POOL EXISTING STUDENT
PULL SO WITH THAT I TURN
IT BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU OKAY IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS YOU WANTED TO
-- HAVE THE ABLE TO RESPOND
I THINK I THINK IT'S IT'S
ALL MEANT TO BE HONEST WITH
YOUR QUESTIONS KIND OF POINT
MADE MY POINT -- THE ONLY --
SPECIFICALLY CITED THAT WE'RE
NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO GROW
DOLLARS IF WE GROW THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS -- -- SOME IMPACTS
OF WEATHER NO IT'S JUST WATER
TEST TO HEAR EVEN JUST THREE
ULTIMATELY -- BUT I THINK IT'S
ALL BEEN HIGHLIGHTED I THINK
YOU DID A GOOD JOB OF ASKING
YOUR QUESTIONS AND I THINK THEY
MADE MY POINT QUITE FRANKLY AND
-- BUT AGAIN I SHARE YOUR GOAL
IN FINDING A PATH TO FINDING
TEEKAY FOR ALL PRE K.
FOR ALL REALLY HAS BEEN YOUR
MISSION MISSING MCCARTY ON A
YOU KNOW FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO ALSO
FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT WE
DO HAVE AN UNDERFUNDED K.
TWELVE SYSTEM TODAY AND TO
JUST ADD STUDENTS DOESN'T
NECESSARILY SOLVE OUR
OUR OUR OUR OUR PROBLEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU I I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW YOU AND I CHAIR
-- YOU KNOW DONALD FRIEND AND
COMMITTEE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS AT IN LENGTH YOU KNOW
GOING BACK TO EARLIER YEARS
AS FAR AS EXPANDING STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IF THAT MONEY
COMES FROM PROPAGATOR OUTSIDE
AND YEAH I CONCUR THAT WE ARE
READILY -- -- UNDERFUNDING
PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT'S WHY
MR MARTUCCI HAD THAT BILL LAST
YEAR TO GET LCF UP TO THAT
FUNDING THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
WHICH WOULD SIGN I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT -- I DO THINK THAT
THERE IS A DIFFERENT EQUATION
HERE THAT WITH THAT PERCEPTIVE
DECLINING AND DECLINING
ENROLLMENT YOU WILL HEAR FROM
SOME YOUR DISTRICTS INCLUDING
MANY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE SPONSORS OF THIS EFFORT
TO DO THIS BECAUSE THEY REALLY
FEEL THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
THING TO DO AND WHEN I'VE
TALKED TO DISTRICTS THEY REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD TO DRESS TOO MUCH
OF NOT -- GETTING AT A PER SE
THEY'RE ASKING THE QUESTIONS
THAT DESPITE OURS WAS ASKING
ABOUT WELL WOULD YOU DO IT
OVER ONE YEAR ENOUGH TO DO IT
PHASES OVER FIVE YEARS OKAY
WE CAN KIND OF STOMACH THAT
WE COULD GET A PHASE IT IN
A KIND OF GRADUALLY ASSUME
THAT THAT INCREASE -- WHAT
ABOUT FACILITIES WHAT ABOUT
-- WORKFORCE TRAINING SO THOSE
ARE THE ISSUES THAT I'VE HEARD
AND WHEN A WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
THAT IT WHEN YOU'RE SHOPPING
A FEW MONTHS -- BUT -- THE
OTHER THING THAT I THINK IT
IS JUST DIFFERENT HERE IS THIS
NOTION THAT WE HAVE SOME MONEY
THAT COULD GO TO THE RAINY
DAY FUND GRANT THAT MONEY
IS NOT AVAILABLE TO SAVE THE
SCHOOLS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
END OF THE RECESSION BUT THAT
HASN'T INTERPLATE WITH THIS --
EXPANSION OF NEW KIDS NTK WITH
NOT HAVING AS MUCH OF A DROP
IN DECLINING ENROLLMENT SO BUT
HERE BUT LOOK WE'RE HERE TODAY
TALKING ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
THREE PROPOSALS -- -- -- ALL
ONE TIME PROPOSALS BUT I THINK
THAT THE KEY QUESTION IS AND
AGAIN I ASKED AS THE GOVERNOR
HAS EMBRACED -- UNIVERSAL T.
K.
-- TO MAKE SURE IT IS NOT
MEANS TESTED THAT MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES CAN PARTICIPATE AND
SO IN THE GOVERNOR PUTS IN
ONE TIME MONEY I SEE IT BERMAN
FINANCE SAYS THAT YOU THINK
THERE'S ENOUGH MONEY TO ADD
TO TO ACCOMMODATE THIS INITIAL
EXPANSION AND AND THAT AGAIN
THROUGH THE OUT YEARS AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY
-- IS THE PROPOSAL FOR THE ONE
TIME MONIES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- I KNOW WE'LL HEAR
FROM PEOPLE IN PUBLIC COMMENT
WOULD THINK ABOUT THIS AND
AGAIN THE RECOMMENDATION HERE
IS NOT TO TAKE ACTION TODAY
ANYWAY THIS IS A HOLD OPENED
-- FIFTEEN TILL AFTER THE MAY
REVISE WE HEAR THE OVERALL
PROP NINETY EIGHT A PACKAGE --
SELF WE CAN NOW SING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS WE CANNOT PROCEED
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS AND AGAIN
I WILL ASK THAT THE -- THE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IF FROM -- TO KEEP THIS TO THE
ISSUES THAT WE ADDRESS TODAY
SO WE WILL HEAR THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ISSUE THAT MEDIC CAL
BUILDING BILLING STOOD MENTAL
HEALTH SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA
IN THE COLLABORATIVE -- FOR
EDUCATION EXCELLENCE -- ISSUE
AT A LATER DATE WITH THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC COMMENT WITH THAT IN
THE FUTURE SO DO WE HAVE PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE TODAY SO
IF YOU CAN HEAD OVER TO THE
-- MICROPHONE HOW MANY PEOPLE
DO WE HAVE THE LINE BY THE WAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU HOLD ON
A SEC THIS KIND OF WHEN I
GUIDE HOW MUCH TIME WILL
ALLOCATE REPUBLICAN SURE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THREE --
PUBLIC COMMENTS WAITING OKAY
YEAH SO WE WILL GIVE EACH
PARTICIPANT NINETY SECONDS A
MINUTE AND A HALF FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SO PLEASE BEGIN
HELLO AS PAUL REVERE EVERY
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVE
IS WORKERS THREE THE NEXT
AVAILABLE FOR TOMORROW WITH
EACH PASSING DAY TODAY PROBABLY
DROP OUT IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
ALL OF THE LABOR IT IS REPORTED
I HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND LOST
CALIFORNIA ALREADY WITH SAC
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT C.
ONE HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX LESS
STUDENTS FOR THIS CURRENT
YEAR AND YOU ALL SIT HERE
AND TALK ABOUT PADDING THOSE
NUMBERS BY FORESEEN SMALLER
CHILDREN INTO A SCHOOL SYSTEM
THAT'S NOT EVEN OPEN HOW FAR
WILL THIS GO I DEMAND EACH OF
YOU TO SUPPORT S.
C.
R.
FIVE TO REMOVE GOVERNOR NEW
SENSE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT IS THE POVEDA CARTEL
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER I JUST
WANT TO ANNOUNCES WELL FOR
PEOPLE WATCHING THAT CAN'T SEE
THE NUMBER I BELIEVE IT'S ON
YOUR SCREEN BUT AGAIN THE CALL
IN NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE GIVE ME PROJECT
HE TALK ABOUT DECLINING
ENROLLMENT I JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHY SACRAMENTO COUNTY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS IT DIDN'T
NINE KIDS ENROLLMENT HOW CAN IT
HOW CAN THEY ROAMING GET LEFT
BUT THEN HUNDRED APPARENTLY
SACRAMENTO I DON'T CARE WHERE
THEIR KIDS CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL
AT ALL NOT EVEN JUST LEARNING
THEY CANNOT GO THERE TONIGHT
I FIFTY SEVEN YEAR OLD TWINS
YOU HAVE NEVER STARTED SCHOOL
NEVER AND DIFFICULT ENTRY IN
EVERY SCHOOL AROUND IT IS THE
NINE AND BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
FULL WHICH IS AGAINST THE LAW
YOU CAN'T DO THAT -- SACRAMENTO
COUNTY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS STILL DENYING THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS THEIR KIDS ARE UPS SF
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO MY TWINS HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR MONTHS THEY HAVE
A FIFTY SIXTY DAY DEADLINE
DAVID WOULD YOU PER MONTH AND
THERE'S NO END IN SIGHT WHEN
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND ON
TOP OF THAT THE DEBATE CAN WE
START DISTANCE LEARNING I DON'T
KNOW THEIR THE CAP TO HOW MANY
KIDS TO BE IN JUNE SESSION --
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
CONSIDER FULL WHEN THERE'S NO
ONE IN SCHOOL THANK YOU CAN
GO ON A TABLET THERE DIRECTOR
DENIED ACCESS EVEN GO ON THE
COMPUTER AND TRY TO LEARN
PHYSICAL IMAGERY AND EVERYTHING
AROUND IT HAS SAID THEY'RE FULL
WE CANNOT DRIVE FIFTEEN MINUTES
TO IN ANOTHER SCHOOL THE
DIFFICULT ARE LEGALLY MANDATING
TO ALLOW KIDS ENTERING SCHOOL
WHY ARE THEY DO NINE KIDS IN
SCHOOL HE CLEARLY EDUCATION
SUPPORT A WIRED I FEDERAL EVER
STARTED DO NOT AFTER THAT THANK
YOU WHAT ONE YOUR YOUR TIME'S
UP BUT I WILL REFERENCE THAT I
BELIEVE YOU ARE IN MY DISTRICT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO SO IF YOU
WANT TO CONTACT MY OFFICE WE
CAN INQUIRE WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO SEE WHY YOUR TWINS
-- DON'T HAVE PROPER ENROLLMENT
SO IF YOU CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
MY OFFICE WILL CERTAINLY TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT FOR YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
MY ROLLER SKATES MCCARTY RIGHT
YOU'RE VERY GENEROUS TODAY I
MEAN NOT ONLY SECONDS INSTEAD
OF SIXTY LUCKY ME OUR EYES EVER
GOING TO GO UP I CAN WAIT A
SECOND YOUR TIME IS BEGINNING
PLEASE START YOU'LL LOVE THAT
TIME OR MCCARTY AND I HEARD
YOU SAY VACCINE MCCARTY AND I
HEARD YOU SAY VACCINE O'DONNELL
SO IT'S NOT ON THE CENSORSHIP
LIST AND BY DEFINITION THE
CALL WOULD SHOT IS NOT A
TRUE VACCINE IT IS M.
I.
R.
N.
A.
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIZATION ONLY HERE
IS THE SCIENCE CLASS PART
OF THE COMMENTS TRADITIONAL
VACCINES CONTAIN CHOPPED
UP PIECES OF THE VIRUS SO
THAT THE RECIPIENT CAN GET
IMMUNITY WITHOUT GETTING THE
DISEASE THE MRNA KOPET VACCINE
CONTAINS GENETIC SOFTWARE THAT
CAUSES THE RECIPIENT CELLS
TO MANUFACTURE THE ANTIGEN
ON THEIR OWN WHICH THEY HOPE
THEY'RE NOT SURE YET WELL THEN
CAUSE AN IMMUNE RESPONSE COOL
IDEA LET'S SEE IF IT WORKS
OR NOT BOTH ARE UNPROVEN AND
HAVE NOT COMPLETED CLINICAL
TRIALS WHO NEEDS CLINICAL
TRIALS WHEN YOU HAVE THE WHOLE
GLOBAL POPULATION TO TESTED ON
WHERE YOUR EYES MCCARTY WHERE
ARE YOUR EYES -- DONALD WHAT
COULD GO WRONG THIS IS NOT A
VACCINE IT IS TECHNOLOGY AND
YOU OTHER THAN THE CHILDREN
AND MY KINDERGARTEN TEACHER
HER HUSBAND WELL NEVER
TAKE THIS SHOT MY FOUR
KIDS WILL NEVER TAKE IT SO
YOU CAN HAVE ALL OF THEM
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OR YOUR TIME IS
UP I DON'T USUALLY RESPOND
TO PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I WILL
NOTE THAT THIS VACCINE IS
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT VOLUNTARY
SO IF INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
WANT TO TAKE A BACKSEAT
YEAH
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE PEOPLE ON THE LINE
YES WE DO HELLO FIRST WE
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MAIN
MARKET THERE A GIRL'S DANCE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION EXCUSE ME I
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND
MY COMMENTS ARE SPECIFIC TO
DISTANCE LEARNING ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT OF BOTH
DESIGNATED AN INTEGRATED IS
REQUIRED TO BE PROVIDED IN
THE DISTANCE LEARNING SETTING
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE LACK
OF OR INCONSISTENT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT PROVIDED
TO OUR ENGLISH LEARNERS THIS
CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
MUST BE PROVIDED ON A DAILY
BASIS ACADEMIC AND OTHER
SUPPORTS MUST BE SPECIFIC
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS SUCH AS
DIFFERENTIATING SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION AND TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WHETHER AN
ENGLISH LEARNER IS A NEWCOMER
OR A LONG TERM ENGLISH LEARNER
INSTRUCTION NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE IN ORDER FOR OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS SO I HAVE ONE ON
ONE INTERACTION WITH THEIR
ENGLISH SPEAKING PEERS WHICH IS
CRITICAL FOR FURTHERING THEIR
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY LASTLY WE
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER PROVIDING
STANDARDS BASED ARTS EDUCATION
COURSES INCLUDING MUSIC IN
ORDER TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS
MORE INTERESTED AND ENGAGED
IN THEIR DISTANCE LEARNING
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
AND WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
AGUIAR-CURRY AND MEMBERS
METHOD TRAINED ON THE HAPPENED
CHILDREN NOW AS PART OF
YOUR OVERSIGHT OF DISTANCE
LEARNING WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THE DRAFT
THE STATE AUDIT GUIDE RECENTLY
RELEASED AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
AT WE ARE WORRIED IT WILL NOT
MONITOR DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE GUARD RAIL TO DISTANCE
LEARNING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED LAST SUMMER AND PUT IN
PLACE WITH THE CONDITION ABOUT
THE FACT FINDING IN ADDITION
IT'S CHEN ACCORDION MEMBERS OF
THE PANEL MENTIONED THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND T.
K.
AND EARLY LEARNING PROVIDED
THROUGH STATE PRESCHOOL
AND CHILDCARE AT THE
STATE CONTEMPLATE THE
PLANNING ACT WITH THE G.
K.
WE BELIEVE THE POTENTIAL TO
FINAL PENA THREE STABILIZE
CHILD CARE ESPECIALLY NOW GIVEN
THAT THIS ALREADY FRAGILE WITH
AND HAVE BEEN FOR THE STRAIN
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AND THIS
WOULD INCLUDE INVESTING IN
RATE REFORM AND SYSTEMATICALLY
EXPANDING ACCESS ESPECIALLY FOR
INFANTS TODDLERS AND THREE YEAR
OLDS THAT FOLLOWED INVESTING IN
OUR STATE FOUR YEAR OLD HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HAVE A PROFOUND
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THEIR LIVES
AND RESULT IN A STRONG RETURN
ON OUR INVESTMENT FOR THE
STATE TO SUPPORT THIS GOAL AND
REPAIR CHEESECAKE PREVIN NUMBER
FOUR YEAR OLDS WE BELIEVE
WILL BE CRITICAL TO ATTRACTING
KEY FEATURES OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS INCLUDING AS NOTED
BY A NUMBER OF SPEAKERS AND
SPENDING MORE DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE CHILD TEACHER
RATIOS -- IN ADDITION WE
BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT AT THE
STATE PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING
FOR THIS PURPOSE INCLUDING
INTEGRATING INCREASED YOU
CAN'T -- ATTENDANCE INTO
THE STATE LTFS COMPATIBILITY
CATION FORMULAS AND AND
FINALLY WE'RE REALLY CONCERNED
THAT -- INCENTIVE GRANTS ARE
NOT SUFFICIENT AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE POLICYMAKERS
TO NOT DIRECT FUNDING AWAY
FROM EXISTING KI K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS --
ESPECIALLY GIVEN HOW FAR
BEHIND CALIFORNIA'S IN TERMS
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
COMPARED TO REST OF THE
NATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY MARK
YES WE DO HAVE MORE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP -- OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM BLIND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MR CHAIRPERSON
BROWN THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS -- FIRST OFF JUST
WANT TO SAY WE AGREE WITH
EVERY POINT MR DOLLARS MAY
TWO NIGHT -- DISTANCE LEARNING
IS A CHALLENGING WHICH IS WHY
EDUCATORS WANT TO GO BACK IN
PERSON AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AS WE OUTLINED IN OUR CLASSES
PATHWAY DOCUMENT THAT WE
DISPUTED EARLIER THIS MONTH
IT SEEMS TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
OVERLAP WITH THE DETAILS YOU
SHARED WITH THE SELLERS PLANTS
AND NIGHTS WE APPRECIATE THAT
IN TERMS OF OUR IMMEDIATE
FUTURE -- WE ALSO AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY IT THAT
IS THIS IS GOING TO TAKE MUCH
MORE THAN ONE BUDGET CYCLE TO
CORRECT AND WE'LL TAKE SOME
LONG TERM PLANNING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T JUST GO BACK
TO NORMAL AS I THINK ANOTHER
PRESENTER MADE -- THE POINT
TONIGHT THAT OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM
BEFORE KOBE NEEDED IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE LONG TERM CORRECTION
AND AND WE AGREE THAT -- I
THINK OF IT BROUGHT A LOT OF
THE -- MORE PERTINENT ISSUES
TO LIGHT BUT THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHERS TO -- TO GET TO SO WE
HAVE THE NEED FOR A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION OF REVENUE -- TO
LOWER STUDENT TEACHER RATIOS
PROVIDE EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
AND COUNSELLING EXPANDER TKE
PROGRAM AND EXPANSION OF PARA
EDUCATORS TO HELP BUILD OUR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS BACK UP
TO SNUFF -- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ESPECIALLY
MISTER CHAIR ON EXPANDING
TRADITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
-- AND WILL BE -- SUBMITTED
SOME PROPOSALS LATER THIS
WEEK TO BRING SOME REVENUE
TO MAKE THAT AND SO MUCH MORE
GREAT SUCCESS THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME TONIGHT THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI YES MY NAME IS MICHELLE
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I
AM SO DISGUSTED EVERY TIME I
CALL IN AND I LISTENED TO THE
RANKING AND THE MISINFORMATION
AND THE CLUELESSNESS OF WHERE
FUNDS ARE WHAT THE PLAN IS WHAT
THE NEXT STEP IS NOBODY KNOWS
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND IT'S
BEEN WAITING FOR COBIT I HOME
SCHOOL MY KIDS FOR A REASON
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM HAS FAILED AND I'M NOT
SURE WHO STATED THAT THE CULT
WOULD MATCH THE BACK SCREEN
IS -- VOLUNTARY BUT IN CASE
YOU DIDN'T CHECK WITH YOUR
GOVERNOR OUR GOVERNOR WHO WERE
TRYING TO RECALL HE WANTS TO
MAKE THE SHOT MANDATORY FOR ALL
KIDS TO RETURN THIS GOAL WHICH
WILL BE GENOCIDE AND THAT WILL
BE ON ALL OF YOUR SHOULDERS
YOU ARE ALL I NOTICED ACTIVE
EVERY TIME I CALL IN TO GIVE
YOUR RESEARCH AND YOU REALLY
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON BEHIND
THE SCENES WITH THESE POLICIES
YOU KNOW WHY DON'T WE STOP
PUTTING MARBLE IN FRONT OF OUR
SCHOOLS WHY DON'T YOU GUYS TAKE
THE MONEY AND PUT IT WHERE IT
REALLY BELONGS STOP DECORATING
AND AND WE'RE WASTING MONEY
AREN'T AREN'T GOD KNOWS WHAT
YOU GUYS ARE FAILING THESE
CHILDREN THAT'S WHY I DON'T
EVEN GET MY KIDS TO SCHOOL
BECAUSE I'D DONE A BETTER JOB
THAN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM EVER
COULD HAVE DIED THANK YOU
GUYS SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD EVENING
AND WE GOT A LOT CHAU GRAPH
REPRESENTING THE BANK YET
WAS IN A FIGHT GOAL DISTRICT
AND I MAINLY WANT TO SPEAK
TO THE ISSUE OF HE CAME -- IN
SAN DIEGO ABOUT FIVE NOW THE
ACCESS TO EARLY EDUCATION IS
CRUCIAL FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
THE FACT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
TO MAKE IT A PRIORITY NOT
ONLY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
DECLINING ENROLLMENT WHICH WE
THINK WE CAN HELP WITH THAT
ISSUE BUT ALSO TO INCREASE
ACCESS LOCALLY IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND WE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS BY
THE STATE INCENTIVIZING AND
PRIORITIZING FUNDING FOR T.
K.
A TYPICALLY AB TWENTY TWO
-- IT WORKING TO MAKE THAT
EFFORT I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THAT ISSUE
AND JUGGLING COURAGE TO BAIL
OUT THE PART OF CONSIDERATION
FOR BUDGET DISCUSSION -- WE
THINK THERE ARE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO OFFSET THE FUNDING
THAT WE WOULD BE NECESSARY
AND -- COMMITTEE AGENDA
IDENTIFIED THAT BY UPDATING
THE FUNDING TO THE RAINY DAY
FUND BOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
SACRAMENTO COMES FROM
A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LIKE TO SHARE MEMBERS THIS
IS ONLINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING NEARLY A QUARTER
MILLION CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES IN BOTH K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
BEGIN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR -- THE
MINI CARE WE AGREED THAT ALL
FOUR YEAR OLD DESERVES ACCESS
TO TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
WE APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR THAT YOU CAME
SENATE GRANT PROGRAM BUT WE
WANT UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WE THINK IT'S
UNFAIR THAT CURRENTLY ONLY A
QUARTER OF FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE
PROVIDING ACCESS TO T.
K.
WE ALSO AGREE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SHOULD RECEIVE FULL
YEAR EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING
FOR DECADES ANNOUNCEMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS MICHELLE TOLD
PARLIAMENTARY FROM KIDDING
AROUND WHICH IS AN EARLY
LEARNING NONPROFIT WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT
THE VISION OF THE MASTER
PLAN BY ANY ACT THAT THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
WHICH WE KNOW WE WILL CLOSE
THANKS FOR READING IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY GAP -- WE WOULD
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO GO
FURTHER TO FULLY FUND THE
ON GOING HOT AND EXPANDED
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN FOR
ALL PUBLIC SCHOOL TO CHEESE
TO VOLUNTARILY IMPLEMENTED --
AND WE ALSO URGED ABOUT TWENTY
TO BE NATION ON IMPLEMENTATION
OF KEY QUALITY ELEMENTS LIKE
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER WE
HEARD OF LOWERING THE STUDENT
TEACHER RATIO -- PROGRESSING
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IS A KEY STEP
TOWARD STRENGTHENING A BURKE
TO FIVE EASY SYSTEM AND AS
CHAIR MCCARTY POINTS OUT WOULD
ALLOW SHIFTING FUNDING I'M TO
SERVE YOUNGER CHILDREN ON SO
THAT WE CAN AGAIN -- WITH OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS IN GETTING
THEM READY FOR KINDERGARTEN
AND LYFT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PATTING HER ON
BEHALF OF CURRENTLY H.
CALIFORNIA WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE HAD THIS EVENING AROUND
THE GOVERNOR'S TKA IN BATON
CHEN IS TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
PROJECTS -- AND AND APPRECIATE
HIS ARE YOU TOWARD ACHIEVING
THEM OUT ONE OF THE MASTERS
PLAN RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
PROVIDING UNIVERSAL CRITICAL
TOP IN CALIFORNIA BUT AS THE L.
A.
O.
AND OTHERS COMMUNITY CAN
EXPANSION REQUIRES ON GOING
NOT ONE TIME FUNDING SO WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO FULLY FUND TO
RUBIO YEAH ELEAZER VOLUNTARILY
EXPAND TKA WELL MAKING PROGRAM
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS TO BENEFIT
YOUNG LEARNERS SUCH AS LOWER
TEACHER STUDENT RATIOS FULL
DAY PROGRAMS IN THE STATE BY
TEACHING CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
CURRENT EDUCATION FUNDING
LANDSCAPE INCLUDING THE RAINY
DAY FUND RESOURCE THAT MISTER
COME PROBLEM MENTIONED PROVIDES
A UNIQUE AND PERHAPS ONCE
IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
TO FINALLY ACHIEVE PEOPLE
CRITICAL FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN OUR STATE WE SIMPLY
CAN'T AFFORD TO LET THIS MOMENT
PASS US BY THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD HI KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION BURKE
JUST WANT TO AND SAY THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE IN
PRIORITIZING BACK BEING FOR
LOCALLY BUT YOU BELIEVE IN AND
EXPENSE ALL MITIGATION STRATEGY
FOR RE OPENING COURT BASICALLY
-- REGARDING DISTANCE LEARNING
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A DISTANCE
LEARNING OPTION FOR FAMILIES
THAT SHE TO REMAIN IN THE
BURNING AND THEN ADDITIONALLY
-- EACH CASE THE COURT THE
INTENT OF EXPANDING G.
K.
FOR FOUR YEAR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS OVER TRYING TO IMPLEMENTED
PROPERLY AND WE AGREE -- YOU
KNOW ADEQUATE RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THAT ISSUE THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY WHAT
ONE FORTY SEVEN E.
YOUR MIKE IS OPEN
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN AND THE
FACT ET I ISSUE ONE LEARNING
IMPLEMENTATION I AM A FRESHMAN
CLASS CO PRESIDENT OF THANK YOU
DON'T THINK YOU'RE A SCHOOL A
SCHOOL BY SCHOOL DISTRICT MY
PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY I AM AND
I AM AN ARTISTIC I EIGHTEEN
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PROGRAM OTHER COMMENTS I AM
PREPARED TO PROTECT PATIENTS
AND
IN I.
E.
P.
INCLUDING A ONE ON ONE EIGHT
ASTRUM COOL COMMITTEE I WORRY
ABOUT BOTH EXPECTED NEED BOB
I THINK IT IS STRUGGLE IT IS
VERY I WOULD LIKE TO RESPECT
WE RECOMMEND THE FOLLOWING
FOR CONSIDERATION FOR MAKING
BUDGETARY DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT STUDENT WORKS THAT
WILL MEET ALLOCATING FUNDING
TO PROVIDE COMPENSATORY
SURE IS THIS PERSON WHO DID
NOT RECEIVE ANY OUR MINIMUM
SERVICES DURING SCHOOL CLOSURES
PARTICULATE ALL STUDENTS
AGES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO
AND ALLOCATING FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THE INCONSISTENCY
OF SUPPORT RESOURCES ACROSS
SOUTH BUT INCLUDED A PROVISION
UNSTRUCTURED ASSESSMENTS AND
RELATED SERVICES AND THE FACT
THAT IT WILL BE IMPACTED BUT TO
THE VERY EDGE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THE THIRTY AND ONE WILL BE
OPEN IN THE FUTURE IT REQUIRED
TO BE DISCLOSED HER SEXUAL
NEEDS LIKE MYSELF WHAT THE
THIRD IS THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL INVESTORS ARE THIRTY
AND WE TO POTENTIAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND OUR LOW IN
OUR LAST PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THE EVENING COMES FROM LINE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
HOW CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES THANK YOU
I THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
SPEAK -- MY NAME AND HELLO
YES PLEASE PRESS EIGHT THANK
YOU MY NAME IS AMY I'M CALLING
FROM -- SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA
AND -- MY QUESTION FOR YOU
GUYS AFTER LOSING TO YOU GUYS
ALL DAY -- I DON'T KNOW THREE
HOURS HOW DO YOU PLAN ON BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SITE TO
OPEN THE SCHOOLS AND DO THE
RIGHT THING HOW DO YOU PLAN
ON GETTING THESE KIDS UP TO
SPEED AND HAS MISSED THE ENTIRE
YEAR A THIRD BREAK I AM LIMIT
I AM LET YOU SLEEP AT NIGHT
AT NIGHT
THANK YOU
AND THERE ARE NO MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN